Mobility is is really the ability to do
the things you want to be able to do
with your body do you have your native
range of motion and can you control that
native range of motion
how do we move with ease how do we
maintain flexibility as we age and
address issues before they become
injuries there are ways that you can
change your environment so that these
are just things you do without having to
rely on Willpower or motivation today we
dive deep into all things Mobility with
two legends of movement Kelly and Juliet
start at Dr Kelly starratt is a globally
renowned physical therapist and strength
coach and his wife Juliet is a
three-time whitewater rafting world
champion and CEO of the ready state
which is the mobility coaching company
they founded together they've worked
with some of the world's Premier
athletes as well as everyday average
folks and together they co-wrote the
recently published built to move which
is this sort of holy text on all things
movement your range of motion doesn't
have to change because you age we also
talk about how to Future proof your body
from injury and many other fascinating
and important topics Kelly and Juliet
are just absolute wizards of pain-free
movement and mobility and look we're
only given one body in our lives and
this conversation uh really inspired me
to take further ownership of my body and
I certainly hope it does the same for
you so without further Ado please enjoy
my conversation with Kelly and Juliet
starrette
this episode is brought to you by Roca
[Music]
I think there's still quite a bit of
confusion around what Mobility means and
why people should care about it and so I
think that's one of the things we're
trying to do in the world is continue to
try to sort of clarify what that means
at least to us and and help people
understand why they should care but not
only might just add that
I've had to adopt a mantra the glacial
pace is the Breakneck Pace yes I heard
you say that I love that it is really
difficult to change or to influence or
to give people better tools and let it
permeate
you know at risk of sounding Doom and
Gloom you know Fitness has done a really
good job of becoming very sophisticated
and there are great trusted resources
some of the people we talked earlier
about
maybe we've left a whole lot of people
behind
and if it's starting to happen where we
can have these kind of bigger
conversations then it's it's a
reflection I think of people recognizing
that maybe what we've been doing hasn't
really served them as well as we thought
and that there's a big opportunity
there's I think a mismatch between the
truth and I think we really saw it in
the pandemic of you know how are people
able to self-soothe or take care of
themselves or feed themselves they
didn't have kettlebells at home they
didn't know how to cook and we just sort
of left people behind so it is it is
gratifying very much and I'm also sorry
for popularizing the word Mobility
because I think it's like it's like I
invented the word it's like the least
sexy word ever we're like I can't
believe we've had the same Mobility this
many times in our life well well you
were the first to really popularize it
and then it became part of the common
you know vernacular and you had to it's
so much so that you had to change the
name of your company from Mobility would
the ready State
um but in looking at at you know kind of
telescoping up and trying to understand
what's what has happened the way I see
it is yes you you you kind of cut your
teeth working with Elite athletes
Olympic athletes Special Forces First
Responders all these like kind of Highly
specialized people who are very
performance oriented or or who have like
very specific goals that they're
striving for and through that process
you were able to not only help these
people but you know learn and get you
know uh really you know into the deepest
trenches of what this is all about
um but then you can take that and
through this book and now kind of what
your current focus is to translate that
for the mainstream audience and I think
that the time is really right for this
for a couple reasons the first of which
is
there's an explosion in interest in
longevity and certainly you know a core
principle in trying to live uh you know
your longest best life is your
functional strength and Mobility can you
get up off the ground you know are you
able to move are you able to put a bag
in the you know above your head on the
airplane and all that kind of stuff and
then also
uh this this this this sort of rising
interest in in rewilding our lives right
we this is something you talk about in
the book and and refer to quite you know
quite regularly that we have unwilded
ourselves right and so the principles
that you teach although they're highly
applicable to all of these Elite
scenarios are more broadly applicable
and more profoundly applicable I think
to everybody who's thinking about you
know what's it going to be like when I
turn 80 and and how come I don't feel so
good when all I do is stare at a screen
all day and then go home and watch
Netflix well I think we can even go a
step further and say that in the last
chunk of time where we've got to go in
and see everyone's Dirty Laundry
people's lives are on the line or
professions are on the line about how
their body works it's really given us an
indication of what are core essential
practices off of which you can build
Elite Performance because you understand
that being a professional athlete is
tricky you have family and nutrition and
travel and sleep and there's a lot of
you know Masters to serve in that world
and one of the things that we have come
to realize is that if we could truly
take Sport and realize its potential
then sport was a laboratory through
which we should transform society and
that was that's really been a lens and
one that we weren't I don't think really
ready to adopt fully 10 years ago but
now we're realizing that that's our sort
of our our you know our calling
and in so much that we're trying to get
and take these lessons that way sport
can actually mean more to us it can be a
laboratory and a place a teaching
Hospital a test kitchen where we can
really understand what happens when
people are under stress and all these
different situations and simultaneously
we saw that some of those Basics get
missed by the best in the world they
have blind spots and then we find that a
lot of people are confused about what a
good foundational practice looks like
and we should be able to take those
lessons and actually say hey look we
understand that you're not an elite
athlete but you're just a you know just
a middle-aged dad who wants to stay up
at this local mountain bike club that's
me and what are the ways where I can do
that in the context of my busy life so I
don't have to you know throw everything
away and I think that's a that really
is an opportunity for us to make sense
of all of the you know bright people
working in this high performance world
and I would just add too that the other
sort of lens um through which we uh I
think have evolved as humans over the
last 10 years you mean us together yeah
yeah both of us together but you know
when we wrote Supple Leopard we were
really focused exactly like you said on
you know Elite athletes and how to
perform better and lift more weights and
run faster and that was really our Focus
both as individuals and and in terms of
what message we wanted to put out into
the world but then we've spent the last
year last 10 years raising kids in this
like really quaint Suburban neighborhood
um around busy professional parents who
are not in the Health and Fitness
business at all so while we have this
whole cohort of friends and professional
colleagues who are and they're all like
us optimizing their health and tracking
everything and taking the right
supplements and you know trying whatever
new exercise program is out you know in
contrast we were we're also friends with
a whole community of people who are you
know busy at Executives and attorneys
and people and maybe they never exercise
but but what they what they share
universally is they actually all really
do care about their health and they are
interested in durability and longevity
But ultimately they're very confused
about what to do where to start
um you know we've really become this
note in our community where you know
people anytime there's some new health
thing out people are like should I be
intermittent fasting wait should I
switch to keto should I do the Whole 30
you know should I try f45 wait should I
should I do zone two cardio how much
should I lift and um we've just been
this source of of questions and seen the
amount of confusion that just sort of
everyday people who care about their
health have and they there hasn't been
sort of we wanted to be able to say you
know hey you know like how much should I
sleep here's Bill to move you know how
much should I take care of my body
here's Bill to move
um so it started in this sort of 10-year
evolution of you know spending time in a
community of people who who really are
focused on health and care about
longevity and durability but really have
no blueprint at all yeah it really is a
paradox we've never had greater access
to information but there's this
waterfall of inputs that that ultimately
do nothing Beyond just paralyze us right
because we just don't know what what to
choose like this is something I'm
experiencing right now with a lower back
issue that I have I'm like I'm sure
we're going to get into that because I'm
going to make it all about me but
um but yeah you know you think about
like morning routines or any it's like
oh it's like oh if you want to optimize
you know like optimization and all of
that it's like I don't have three hours
in the morning to like do my sauna and
do my Coldplay and journal my meditation
and stare at the sunlight and then yeah
like and then journal and then I have to
met you know like all these things it's
like for the normal person they're like
just just you know can you just give me
something that works within the
construct of my life I'm not trying to
optimize or be an elite athlete I'm not
going to join the seals but like I just
you know I just don't want to feel like
crap and it would be great if I had a
little bit more energy so you know when
I get home from work and my kids are
demanding my attention yeah and I think
you know your mention of your low back
pain
um is is also sort of a very important
thing that I left out when I talked
about those people in our community I
mean what we see in that in that group
are people who don't really care about
having shredded abs and they don't care
about optimizing at all
um but a lot of them are dealing with
pain and they you know they aren't sure
how to manage that and are worried
that's going to become their identity
and in many cases
um their sort of ongoing pain issues
have taken them out of the things they
love to do physically which then as you
know has all these Downstream
consequences because so much of what's
so you know so much of the community
that many of us get revolves around some
kind of physical activity
or personal identity you're a pickleball
club or whatever it is you do and so
when people get sidelined from being
able to do the things they love
physically it has all of these hardcore
Downstream consequences especially in
terms of their mental health and so
that's kind of the other piece we saw is
that you know these people again you
know they they want to be out of pain
they want to feel good in their body and
they want to be able to you know play a
game of pickleball on the weekends with
their friends like that's their their
goal and we I don't think in the health
and fitness space have been speaking to
those people I think there's a bit of a
change um and a bit more of a focus on
Basics lately you know coming in from
our community but I think you know
you're exactly right like they could
care less about optimizing right
sometimes we get to work in camps and I
was at a big camp for water polo at a
big division one University and so all
of the superstars are there all the
athletes and then there's a hundred
teenagers there and I ask and I do this
all the time I'm like how many people in
here are pain-free
and you would think you know your 15
year old woman like you know can you
have pain and every hand doesn't go up
no one is pain-free the reality is that
this pain is really an experience that
is human and one of the things I think
is happening a little bit which is great
is that we're shifting this narrative
about who owns pain because what we said
for a long time especially in the
athletic Community was pain is a medical
problem
and that trickles down to well I don't
have time to manage my pain or my Pain's
not so bad that I can't do my job or
live my life so I'll just have this
nagging thing until it gets so bad I
can't occupy my role in the family or do
my you know occupy my role on the team
or you know if you if your back hurts
somebody can't go to work that's a
medical emergency
and so one of the things that we've been
trying to shift is saying hey look
there's a whole lot we can do to empower
people to be able to self-soothe without
bourbon without THC or ibuprofen or
opiates the way we literally handled it
as a medical problem people we left
people to become feral and managing
their own pain and I think
as we are getting more complicated or
more complex and sophisticated about
this one of the things we know is that
pain doesn't mean injury it doesn't even
mean tissue trauma damage it's a request
for change so part of what we're trying
to say in this book is hey we can try to
treat pain and use it just as another
metric like if you were stiff this
morning because you're a big workout
yesterday you're not thinking you know
you've got you know some you know you
didn't contract rabies you just are sore
right right from your run and so if we
can shift that narrative a little bit
and then also Empower people that hey
there's a whole lot they can do and some
of that is sleep and some of that is
nutrition and some of that is is down
regulation but all a lot of it is
there's some inputs you can do that are
really safe and really easy and then we
can have the next conversation because
maybe you don't want to go for a walk
because your knee hurts one quick thing
I will add though is that if you want to
make all of my busy working mom friends
like scream at the top of their lungs to
the hills it is tell them to do those
things as a morning routine and tell
them that if they want to be healthy
humans like it literally if you want to
like make a bunch of like 45 year old
women real mad it's that morning routine
stuff yeah because they're like I'm I'm
making breakfast and lunches for my kids
and driving to the drop-off Lane and you
know what are you talking about I should
meditate for half an hour in journal you
know they go crazy so
um you know we definitely we haven't
done a good job of speaking to that
audience well even beyond that I'm
speaking from personal experience as a
time-crunched person who's interested in
their their Fitness you know I know and
who's dealing with some pain right now I
have all kinds of protocols and
exercises and do that and all of them
are like you know kind of small little
things and you know like just air squats
and you know that kind of stuff a lot of
the stuff that's in your book and I
still have a mental barrier to doing
them because like I just want to go
throw some weights around or like get my
workout in and feel like I got something
done and get to the studio and I can't
be bothered and that doesn't even like
account for when you're like trying to
be a competitive athlete and time
crunched where it's all about your
Fitness and your training and the kind
of stuff that you talk about in this
book just feels
um indulgent or something that you would
do uh you know if you had tons of time
which you don't or if you're in a crisis
situation right which obviously has led
me to this place that I'm there so you
know however you want to get there is is
reasonable and rational right it's I
wait till it's crisis that's you know I
like a lot of pressure I'm sort of a
procrastinator and actually lives with a
high pain threshold there's also that
too yeah or you just keep her that's
right I mean so you know one of the
things I think is really
important that we have rap started to
really wrap our heads around is this
behavior modification habit forming idea
and so Juliet points out that you know
we can't just give people lists of
things hey exercise more eat more fruits
and vegetables like that seems not to be
working very well as well as it could
and so some of this I think what one of
the things that I think is good in here
and we actually came up with this idea
working with the Marine Aviation weapons
tactical group
was looking at okay you're very time
crunched and you're under slept we have
24 hours where are we going to fit these
behaviors that don't also ask you to
give something else up how do we expand
what it is you're doing not take away
because if you are coping with your
family and stress and management because
you need to go Peloton or run or
deadlift whatever it is what we don't
want to say is why don't you go to a you
know a balanced class or you know
you're not going to do somewhere and go
to like a one hour balance class you're
like yeah no I'm not doing it so unless
I like be bad at it and like you know
also be bad yeah right yeah so you know
the real question is trying to look at
what a 24-hour day time schedules and
say where are the places we have some
agency and some control and then we
start to say well how can we constrain
and the environment a little bit so that
you don't have to make another
heroic like you know I'm gonna get up
off the couch now and you know in juice
or you know whatever it is that you're
doing it you know we're people have a
finite amount of will how can we shape
the environment so you don't you can do
the right thing automatically without
having to make a heroic decision yeah I
mean that's very similar to the kind of
things that Dan buettner talks about
with respect to the blue zones it's sort
of like looking at these cultures that
have a long history of longevity and
happiness and trying to deconstruct you
know how they've arrived in this place
and then create a template for our
modern world and so much of it is about
making that healthy choice or that
healthy Behavior the convenient and Easy
Choice as opposed to the burdens the
only choice thing yeah otherwise it's
not it's not going to work so Kelly was
just I think as we told you on a ski
trip in Japan
um and he was he had for most of
the trip was sharing a room with another
guy and the guy got a cold so they
needed to separate rooms and they got to
the next hotel and the hotel staff was
kind of freaking out because they're
like well we don't actually have an
extra room and when their guide actually
we pushed a little more and got some
more information from the hotel stuff it
turned out that they just didn't have
like a western room available and by
Western room that means the bed is high
up off the ground and there's you know a
normal like an American sized table and
you know the sink and shower are at our
height
um but they did have plenty of Japanese
style rooms where the bed is on the
floor and the table's on the floor and
you shower sitting on the floor and you
know but in in their mind they're like
well this american guy can't handle this
until he's like I've been waiting
maybe excuse me yeah choose me choose me
but it is you know Kelly took a video of
this room and I was like man you know we
wouldn't all have so much trouble
getting up and down off the floor if we
got up and down off the floor to go to
bed and you know even things like like
the you know he showed me the video the
room and even things like the air
conditioning controls are like at that
level like knee level because the
presumption is you're going to be sort
of you know moving around all around
you're squatting on the ground yeah yeah
and um so so your range of motion is not
one more thing that you have to add in
yeah but yeah we see in those blue zones
it's it's you know people aren't making
a choice every single day to do these
habits that are good for them it's just
it's their their environment is
perfectly set up so they aren't making
Choice it's just what they do and
there's inherent soft
you know less technical I didn't take
this turmeric and do this secret scroll
program
I had to walk to the market and I saw my
neighbors and so suddenly I feel like I
live in a community right and and there
are all of these sort of loose
connections
one of the things that happens is that
all of those behaviors start to stack
and I think that's one of the the
problems we have experts Matt Walker's
book is great
um but sometimes you you fail to kind of
think about how well my non-exercise
activity during the day the number of
steps actually makes me tired enough to
actually fall asleep and you know I
start making decisions about some of the
things I'm going to do and put in my
body not put in my body because it'll
affect my sleep later on and and
suddenly what we start to see is that
man if we get people who are rested they
start to feel better and their pain
starts to diminish or their brain
becomes less sensitive or easily
sensitized or perceiving their body as a
threat and then we start to roll a
little bit you know and then you want to
move a little bit more you're a little
bit more excited at four o'clock when
you have a window of opportunity so I
think that's one of the magic pieces
here is how do we construct a day-to-day
that isn't crazy that anyone can wrap
their heads around that also just begets
these one plus one equals three moments
yeah just nudging you gently yeah in the
right direction you know repeatedly
throughout the day every single day and
I'm like you rich I want to suffer and
breathe hard yeah you know if I and and
I also doesn't count for yeah
exactly like I feel like I have right I
do that can suffer I have one hour a day
sure
yeah I have um I have like let's say one
hour in my time crunch schedule a day
and I'm always gonna default to choosing
to do some form of suffering
um you know whether that's a crossfit
workout or mountain biking or something
like that I'm always going to choose
that I'm never going to be the person
who's like I should probably take a
recovery day and instead I'm going to go
to a yoga class and I enjoy yoga but I
mean I am never going to be someone who
chooses going to yoga over doing a
workout if I have if I only can choose
one
um and so I'm in the same boat as you in
in order for me to actually figure out
ways to do some of these sort of range
of motion Mobility practices and
practice things like balance like it has
to just be sort of like baked into other
things I'm doing otherwise I live
literally won't do it because I often
feel like I really have that one sacred
hour a day to do what I want and what I
want is work out
we're brought to you today by Roca
glasses are not something you normally
think about as a piece of performance
gear which when you think about it is
kind of insane because you can't perform
at your best if you can't see well the
Geniuses at Roka basically rebuild
eyewear from the ground up no matter how
active you are or how much you sweat
these things never slip or fall off your
face they're super durable they look
awesome and they've got tons of super
classy modern styles to choose from I've
been rocking rokas for about four years
at this point I love them I'm a big fan
of the Hamilton style and gloss black
that's this Frame right here as well as
clear or I guess they call them vintage
on the website and if you want to try
them out for yourself you can do that
right now and unlock 20 off your order
with the code Rich Roll at roca.com or
you can click the link in the
description below okay back to the show
you mentioned earlier that there's a lot
of confusion around what you mean when
you talk about Mobility so let's just
clarify that and I kind of want to build
on that to get into the various you know
principles that form the framework of
this book and your philosophy
well I mean I'll start and maybe yeah
take a swing out go take a swing at this
I think I mean at this point you ought
to be able to Define it right yes yes
um to us uh you know Mobility is is
really the ability to be able to move
freely through your environment and do
the things you want to be able to do
with your body whatever those things may
be now we we offer a lot of tools which
we call mobilizations which are things
you can do to help improve your mobility
and range of motion but you know to us
at the highest level it's a it's the
ability to move freely ideally without
pain or at least minimizing pain and
feel to do the things you love to do and
if I added it how did I do pretty pretty
good for an attorney I uh you've been in
the game for a minute I can tell
I would add
your body everyone agrees that your
shoulder should be able to do certain
things and that your spine should be
able to do certain things and your hips
should build certain things every
physician every orthopedic surgeon every
physical therapist we all agree how much
shoulder is normal how much your ankle
should be able to move
the problem is that we don't give people
benchmarks for what is normative or what
you should be able to do and our lives
sometimes don't ask us of that and so
suddenly when we have pain or a problem
that range of motion is never part of
the conversation about hey I see that
your steering wheel doesn't go all the
way to the left let's just make sure
that you can you know the pilots where
they take off you know they check to
make sure everything's working right
so we could also Define mobility as do
you have your native range of motion and
can you control that native range of
motion so are you a skilled person and
what Juliet said is all of that is
important but really what is it you want
to do in your world and environment and
how do you want to express this body
that's the most important thing and I
think that's where we got in the weeds
you know yeah hip range of motion is
important yeah yeah but if it prevents
you from doing something or you're
having pain and that's also conjoined
with the fact that you don't have access
to that range maybe that's the reason
you should care well I'm like let me
just give you one example like if you
just asked anyone on the street like do
you care about your hip range of motion
they're going to be like no why would I
care about that
um but but as an example we were
recently talking to a friend of ours who
has a four-month-old baby and has both
sets of parents visiting and their his
parents are like in their mid-60s so
um you know not that much older than us
and they uh his mother is able to get up
off get up and down off the ground and
sit with the baby but his mother-in-law
can't get down onto the ground or up off
of the ground and so can't sit on the
floor and play with the grandchild and
that's one of those things that you
don't think about until right it's like
a use it or lose it kind of thing but
like that right there is hip range of
motion so you may not care athletically
about hip range of motion because you're
not trying to run faster or lift more
weights or you know whatever an athlete
might need to care about hip range of
motion for but you know most people
would say man do you know do you want to
be able to sit on the floor and play
with your grandchild when you have one
and they'd be like yes I do
um and so you know that's one of the
reasons why people should care about
their hip brain's range of motion right
I I feel that humans are not very good
at casting their gaze that far into the
future though so true especially like
it's not if you're 25 you have yeah like
yeah you're just like I'll deal with
that when I can't do you remember that's
not gonna happen to me yes especially
with an elite athlete like forget about
it right so the barrier to being able to
you know convince somebody that these
things are important has to be it's like
a high bar for you right to like
communicate with people like hey you
know we can talk about longevity how
long do you want to live what is it that
you want to be able to do when you're 80
and 90 Etc but when you're 30 even in in
your 40s and and you're essentially
pain-free or you don't have some kind of
injury uh that's you know that that's a
challenge like you know but it is true
that like whether it's heart disease
diabetes you know any kind of brain
degeneration similarly with our physical
bodies like these things are progressive
and if you're not working on this stuff
far in advance of those aging years
you're going to have a problem but if
you do undergo you know you know sort of
shoulder the responsibility of doing
these things that you guys talk about so
much you're taking out this insurance
policy to be able to do all those things
in your later years but it's just that
humans are not good at like you know
evaluating the cost benefit and now
process of these sorts of things and
your environment gives us a lot of cues
or guides us into poor decisions I just
I think New York Times had an article
just recently about how some of our
Foods hijack our brain chemistry right
our modern Foods Zoom mommies we just
think oh they're so good
so here's a story I was a young physio
student watching the cardiac catheter
lab and I'm watching a really wealthy
kid a wealthy man in San Francisco and
his whole family's outside and he has
three beautiful daughters which I can
start to like put myself in his shoes is
this amazing wife Killer Law Practice
he's rich and every definition of the
term he's one life and he's in there
having three stents put in his heart and
he's overweight and what I thought in
that moment was if this guy has every
resource and every reason to live and
it's still that hard to change and to
make these things to keep himself alive
with his family what what recourse does
an average person mortal person without
his resources have and really that was a
kind of a shocker and I think if I'd
video the two women you know putting in
the catheter like chain smoking you know
like as a matter of fact that may have
showed him that video maybe that would
have changed his behavior but you know
it's really difficult to sort of untang
single what seems like the biggest
gordian knot in your life where do I go
especially since sometimes we don't see
the results right away yeah
so when
when when talking about mobility and
movement you know how do you diagnose
somebody's Mobility like everybody you
know you guys have like this superpower
you can like look at somebody just
sitting or standing or walking and be
like oh the I see 10 things wrong with
like what's happening there like most
people don't have that ability and don't
think about that kind of stuff uh you
know the average person if they're
pain-free is gonna say well this is not
good enough I can walk and I can get up
and sit down and all that kind of stuff
so where does one begin to try to
self-diagnose and understand
um their own uh Mobility capacity
limitations and and what they should be
focused on working on
well in this book we we literally
identify five areas where we think that
if people just kept an eye on it like
just kept an eye on it a Vital sign just
yeah we call them Vital Signs because
these ten things yeah with these ten
vital signs but we specifically chose
the word Vital sign because it it
started coming up more and more in the
pandemic actually everyone was like
tracking all these Vital Signs like
their seo2 and you know obviously
everybody knows that 120 over 80 is like
okay blood pressure and if you go over
that it's something you should keep an
eye on and so that's why we we thought
well if if regular people can keep an
eye on a Vital sign like blood pressure
then why can't there be some movement
specific or health specific Vital Signs
and so
um you know obviously the human body is
the most complicated thing in the known
universe
um but we really tried to boil it down
to a few areas of range of motion we
thought people should keep an eye on or
that we consider to be Vital Signs and
we do have these simple tests in the
book that people can just do once and
sort of say okay this is where I'm at
you know this is something I need to
keep an eye on on this is something I'm
doing great at and and you know and then
the things we suggest for people to work
on them we think we've suggested you
know things that they can literally do
like while they're watching Netflix at
night or while they're still sitting at
their office like we've really tried to
make it so that you don't have to go to
the one hour Mobility balance class and
you know journal in the morning in order
to get it in order to get these things
done
um but you know I think they're just
some simple tests I think if everybody
had a real Baseline of what their range
of motion was in their big movers their
hips their shoulders their ankles and
and just literally kept an eye on it
turns out everyone has a universal
language
running everyone knows when I say run
everyone knows exactly what I mean right
this is why the running Community is
global if we use yoga as a movement
language everyone has probably done yoga
a little bit everyone knows what
chaturanga downward dog is so we we have
some touch tones of movement that we can
all agree on if I say push-up everyone
knows what a push-up is
but what's nice about that is we now
have this formal language of diagnostic
movement that everyone has heard of or
at least been exposed to and it's not
the language of rehab I think rehab gets
confusing there's so many ways to
restore position or help to activate or
normalize and and that is like hey we I
speak Esperanto but I speak classic
Greek and this is my but this training
language is pretty ubiquitous and one of
the things that Juliet pointed out was
when we can make some of these
Diagnostics in that normative language
of squatting Up and Down Standing on one
leg you know suddenly you know can you
get into this position and squeeze your
butt so only we have a universal
language that reflects the movements
that we do if I say lunge usually
everyone knows what a lunge looks like
or if a push-up looks like we're putting
your arms over your head so that I think
is a way where we can begin to cast a
bigger net and have people come into
understanding what it is maybe that
they're limiting or what they're we're
having struggle with and you know we set
some booby traps in this book you know
if it's pretty shocking we had we were
hanging out with one of our super strong
badass athlete friends who struggle to
get up on us now off the ground yeah and
he was like whoa my hips and I was like
oh your hips tight like I didn't know
and I think when we kind of confront
people with tests and that we think are
very reasonable because we've gotten to
see the world a little bit and they're
confronted with it then they are knowing
hey maybe that's something I need to
work on I think again creating that that
Vital sign line helps people to make
decisions once they know are they above
or below right so it early in the book
you have this test
you know it's like okay let's see what's
up like cross your legs uh you know
lower yourself down into a cross-legged
position and now you know try to stand
up without using your hands or you know
kind of using the side of your legs to
like you know not yourself go do it and
I was able to do it but like it was hard
harder than I thought it would be my my
back kind of hurt the Rich Roll I mean
you're like come on you're like a legend
well my like here's the thing and
this is kind of like what I wanted to
get into which is
just because if you're an elite athlete
or super fit like these are not
necessarily predictors of whether you
have great range of motion or or
mobility and and in fact it could be
quite the opposite because you're so
specialized at a certain subset of
activities that it makes you kind of
brittle in in terms of being like a
robust overall like you know mobile
functional flexible athlete I mean Kelly
I know you grew up in Europe and were
exposed to all different kinds of sports
and became this like generalist and that
was sort of the root of like you know
all of the work that that you've done
since and appreciating like the
importance of of you know having like a
robust battery of different kinds of
activities that you do as an athlete but
Elite athletes are just good at one
thing right and so actually that makes
them kind of fragile in the context of
potentially yeah overall like you know
kind of stability Mobility Etc and how
do you in an elite population what are
our minimums and we can we can for the
people who are nerding out on this deep
you know if I'm an elite Sprinter so
Stuart Millen of Altus tracking I've
never met him but like on Twitter I
don't have like his feed and like all
the shout out so he's one of the
greatest coaches I've ever met yeah but
Stu and I got into this conversation
about how much dorsiflexion ankle range
of motion his Elite Sprinter is needed
right where he's worked coaching Andre
DeGrasse like pretty good Sprinter and
he's like my sprinters only need zero
they need zero degrees and I was like
totally agree that's how much they need
to do their sport
but does he need more range of motion in
his hips and ankles moving downstairs
and he was like oh wait what what and
then I was like does he train do you go
to the weight room do you need more than
some ankle range of motion zero ankle
range of motion to
form the training so what we can start
to say is do you have enough range of
motion and as a coach I want to make
sure you have enough range of motion so
you don't kind of create alternative
strategies to solving movement problems
and I think one of the the problems with
being a human being is we're so robust
for a long time until something changes
or we can't get away with a strategy
that worked for us you may even be the
best in the world at using this strategy
but that strategy doesn't actually hint
at the possibility or total possibility
of your physiology that if we improved
your hip extension your ability to get
your knee behind your butt effectively
we actually can make you more efficient
more effective and potentially solve or
prevent weird tweaks in the system like
your low back pain or your knee pain so
on the one hand we with those athletes
we want to give Credence to hey your job
is to do this sport what are the
minimums so that we don't end up
creating and sometimes times we have to
use pain as a diagnostic oh you're
starting to get achy let's keep an eye
on that but for the rest of us we have
an opportunity to create a little bit
more robust platform of generalism right
and one of our tests with all of our
athletes we're like oh you think you're
a good athlete jump into a yoga class
let us know how you do there you stand
on one foot and breathe oh you couldn't
oh maybe your Elite program isn't so
Elite you can't even do downward dog and
take a breath so this is we've been like
totally against Sports specialization
for kids and we've been like really
trying hard not to have our own kids
become Specialists they both play water
polo and we sent them this with this
winter in Tahoe to a pilates class and
they were destroyed for like four days
and these are kids who you know are
training all the time so you know we're
trying to
um this isn't really related to your
question but you know we are always like
hey if you think your program is so
great like go try someone else's program
yeah if you love CrossFit go do some
other program and see how you fare right
especially if you're not an elite
athlete obviously Elite athletes need to
get so specialized and they have to I
think leave a a lot of things behind
right if you look at Elite cyclists it's
like well they have zero upper body
strength on purpose but you know for the
rest of us it's like hey we should all
you know become generalists and at least
try try some of these other things
including our own kids it is crazy how
how untransferable some of that like you
know a real specialized Fitness can be
like if you're a Tour de France cyclist
you're so like yeah you have zero upper
body strength or whatever you know like
you're so adapted and efficient at doing
this one thing but the minute you take
that person and put them into some other
kind of environment they're they're
hapless right and there isn't like a
robustness to all of that and you know
look you have to do that to be at the
highest level of that Sport and you know
any athlete who's trying to be an elite
in their specific thing is going to get
really good and efficient at that one
thing but there's gonna be
atrophies of other muscle groups and all
kinds of other you know sort of
Downstream uh byproducts of that
specialization that create physical
workarounds right like so I'm just as
somebody who you know I love the fact
that you've worked with swimmers I come
from a swimming background and then did
this Triathlon thing and you know got
cut very efficient at that one thing but
became like really not overall like all
that stable like my like you know I used
to be really flexible as a swimmer and I
had great balance in yoga and all that
and like a lot of that like now when I
try to do that I'm like wow like I'm
like kind of messed up like I have a lot
of work to do and now I've got this back
pain and everyone's telling me I got to
get my glutes to Fire and I was like I
don't even know what that means
you know I know you know that's like one
of those internets that's like one of
those internet things that people say
you're like get your glutes I have
consulted with lots of bright people
who've given me great advice and and and
and you know there's and and it's been
beneficial to me but there also is that
paralysis to too where it's like you
have conventional uh Western medicine
people telling me like you 100 need
surgery and then a whole battery of you
know alternative modalities and
practitioners all of which are really
great people who've given me a lot of
tools but also it's sort of like there's
so much like I just don't quite know
what to do
if we pull that apart the first thing is
I think we have confused people about
what is a health practice
and so I think we can actually take
exercise out of it if you have any 90
year olds or 100 year olds in your
family a lot of people listening do how
fit and Jacked are they they probably
came of an of age in a generation where
they did not but they were doing
something good genetics plus some
behaviors good relationships they eat
they right they moved a ton they were
always moved I just saw a world record
set in the 5K by that 90 year old woman
did you see that I did yeah I was like
she can outrun me that's she's amazing
so one of the things we can do is help
to pull that apart because I think what
we said was as long as you could just
crush it on the Peloton you're good
right and and it was easy to measure
that cardiorespiratory Fitness
cardiometabolic Fitness and get a
wattage but it doesn't speak to all the
Wonders and ranges so if you look at
something like Joseph Pilates and what
he was trying to solve you can really
see genius in his methodology and system
if you jump into any yoga class there
are positions that are foundational to
the function of the human and that's why
yoga will persist forever can you get
into this end range position where you
don't have a lot of control can you
breathe and stabilize there I mean that
is just a practice that you could do
forever layer on to anyone and I any of
my athletes ask me I'm like yeah yoga
whenever you want to do it it's one of
those all you can eat buffets
one of the things that we see then is if
we sold that you know in the season we
have this kind of competitive Time
Sports specialization training Sports
specific training and the only goal is
to make you a better triathlete that's
the season but we come out of the Season
we're into General physical preparedness
where we can start to open up a little
bit and say hey I see that the session
cost or the sport cost caused you to
specialize or miss some ranges and
that's what we're not typically doing
with a lot of Seasons especially as we
go year round in our kids you know we
you said we used to play all these
different sports
we used to allow the different exposure
to these positions and shapes and
different things account for all of the
possibility and variability and as that
play has gone diminished as the as the
amount of exposure has come diminished
we're realizing we're having to teach a
lot of formal movement skills to kids
and really good athletes because they
didn't have it as a child so in season
there's only one goal to win and we're
gonna we're gonna burn everything we
need to do on the bonfire of winning and
keep you in the game and minimize and
the second the season's over we start to
expand that a little bit that makes
sense and that that's an easier way to
wrap your head around to say it's okay
that you became hyper specialized but we
didn't have the tools and didn't prepare
you to say okay now I'm out of season
what's essential to make me robust again
and I would say too that um you know
just in the broader community and I see
this a lot with parents of kids I know
that are doing Athletics is I can't tell
you how many times a parent has asked me
well I really want to get my kid into a
mountain and bike specific strength and
conditioning program or what that's
called mountain bike secret strength and
conditioning program should my kid who
swims be doing and you know our response
to that is always like well they need to
do General physical preparedness like
every kid probably could stand to
practice balance and get more agile and
get a little bit stronger and you know
work on their motor control and
stability like you know coordination I
think every kid and adult could stand to
do all of those things but I do think
this whole idea of you know well I if
I'm a specialized athlete then all of
everything I need to do is specialize
it's like you know it's it's become part
of our psyche yoga kettlebell Hill
Sprints that's a pretty
vicious combination I mean you're gonna
go a long way like that
how many uh how many Tour de France
cyclists do you do you have like doing
kettlebell
during the season yeah
one of the things that I think is
amazing and you know this you run into
and worked with so many mutants you know
uh Peter Sagan could be a world champion
in multiple Sports I think he's that
talented
you know Levi light Palmer is a very
good family friend for a long time you
know he grew up ski racing he's a really
good athlete and sometimes I think we
it's easy to pull the athleticism out
you know if you look at you know the
best athletes in the world they were
always good athletes and Athletics they
didn't necessarily just you know I do
this one little thing so you know what
we're finding though is if you want to
win you have to be durable and suddenly
durability comes in the form of some
really simple strength training how much
strength training in season enough not
to ruin your surfing not enough not to
ruin your sport enough that you you know
and I you know was we
one of the things we're always asked to
do is we would come in and can you help
us untangle this we want to win make it
through the season longer and we have to
look at all of the pieces
tell me about your sleep oh my sleep is
wretched okay it's really hard for us to
understand what's going on we one time
we're working with uh a CrossFit Games
champion
who was having this really weird knee
pain and you know my friends are
brilliant coaches and I'm not bad and we
were talking about things ultimately she
was traveling alone without her partner
and she slept with the TV on at night
because it made her feel safe in the
room but that TV on all night long kind
of messed up her sleep a little bit
right she didn't actually recover and
that was what made her brain start to
perceive her knee as a problem so it's
important that we're looking at all of
the features that kind of go into making
a robust person and sometimes it is
fueling believe it or not and sometimes
it is you don't have any range of motion
here and some of it is you're not even
you know strong in this position so it's
that's why I think these single
approaches don't necessarily work we
always have to take a systems approach
yeah and in the book you have these you
know these 10 vital signs you go through
them chapter by chapter that begins with
you know sort of getting up how do you
get up off the ground I mean it's like
basic stuff right but then it's like hip
extension like to you you nailed it
right like I go ahead no just that but
if I grab someone off the street and say
I got 20 bucks if you can do this you'd
be shocked at how we have set the bar
has gotten away from us and has gone
very low right and and in addressing
that like back to the whole like where
we've become un unwilded and we need to
rewild ourselves this conversation often
is is is is rather binary and I'm
thinking about my friend Tony riddle I
don't know if you know who Tony is do
you know who Tony is like the natural
light he's this guy in the UK and oh yes
he was uh you know he was a strength
coach and had a gym and you know had
this lifestyle and and had a sort of an
existential crisis and and now he's kind
of like this rewilding expert who has
um broken some amazing records and
barefoot running like he runs Barefoot
all over the UK and and uh and holds
these Retreats and has kids but he's
taken all the furniture out of his house
and there's no chairs and like it's all
like you know Japanese and you know
you're crouching and you're squatting
and you're it's all you know this kind
of movement and breath work and a lot of
the things that you talk about
but I guess the point I'm trying to make
is that
it's rather extreme like you need the
extremes as an example like here's a guy
who's really doing it you know but for
most people the moms in your
neighborhood or whatever they're not
gonna like get rid of the chairs in
their house that's right so it's like I
see you guys like in the middle as a
translator of of what works and you know
the principles behind kind of what
Tony's doing but but translating it in a
way that is accessible for like the
person who lives in the world I mean
you're exactly right like nobody in our
neighborhood is going to get rid of
their living room couch and you know
Furniture yeah in order to couch in a
way yeah there's like no way anybody's
doing that I agree with you but yeah I
mean I think you're exactly right I mean
I think that's we're trying to really
come at this from like the most
reasonable place we can which are you
know what are the things that you can do
that that can also exist within your
normal environment you know like we have
we have a couch and chairs in our living
room but we happen to have some mats in
our living room that you can sit on so
we can sit on the floor and be
comfortable as well and so we're just
trying to really strike that balance
once all the time by saying hey it is
important to take care of your body we
believe in real rewilding the body like
we're total fans of anything related to
rewilding but it's also got a fit within
the context of people's lives I mean I
think you know the inconsistency the
third rail in this book of course is
food because everybody you know the food
thing is is so charged and such a part
of people's identity
um you know but one of the things that
people I know don't want to do is
they're like well I'm not going to
follow anything that is not going to
allow me to go out to dinner with my
friends every so often on the weekends
you know if I have to follow a diet that
means I can't enjoy a community meal
with my friends like I'm out right and
you know so many of the the diets and
suggestions people have I mean they
can't eat dinner with their kids or they
can't go out to dinner on the weekends
with their friends and you know for most
people that trade-off and loss of
community and connection just isn't
worth it from a health standpoint and so
you know we really try to think about
like what can people actually do within
the context of like being a regular
person who wants to like be a normal
part of society and not totally on the
frenches Juliet has done a she is into
nutrition has done some nutrition
coaching and like some some studying
nutrition through Precision Nutrition I
hate that stuff it just doesn't speak to
me and I I see all the third rail
opportunities like you know the the cuts
on the internet I'm gonna get if I say
something be careful Get Ready Get Ready
kills yeah but I had to back into it
because we had to talk about the health
of your tissues and we had to talk about
your healing properties and I deal with
people who are injured you know
oftentimes there's two cohorts of people
who come and see us professionally at
the high level I used to win I'm not
winning anymore why am I winning help me
I got injured winning and I I don't want
to be injured because it's keeping from
winning and it turns out micronutrients
are hugely important to your healing and
your body and when I mean micronutrients
about vitamins and minerals and what is
the revolution in performance nutrition
food that's what we're now back in Alan
Lim Stacy Sims you know hey are you
eating fruits and vegetables yes or no
one or zero because that that you know
no shade on a 900 calorie cup of coffee
but there's no micronutrients in that
fat MCT bomb that you're having it's not
actually I mean it's it's a fuel but
it's not a vitamin so it's no
nourishment there's no nourishment yeah
so if I'm going to try to get you to use
all this collagen you're taking you
better have some vitamin C on board well
where does vitamin C come on we might
just taking more pills and eating this
this ground bison is that my recipe for
the future and so what we've tried to do
here around the nutrition piece because
we had to in our work to be able to talk
about keeping muscle mass on or leaning
out or body comp position or just having
what you need on board and it turns out
people don't eat enough fruits and
vegetables period anywhere especially
kids shocker right and so we could we
could start there and what we try to do
is cast this net and saying you're
vegetarian cool I respect that let's
make sure you're getting some protein
and you're actually getting fruits and
vegetables as a vegetarian you're vegan
cool we respect that your carnivore cool
you can eat these berries with your you
know your Raw Liver whatever that is
that you need to do to be you and
identify but there are these certain
metrics and bass lines principles
principles that underpin that that give
you a lot of freedom and that's we do
think that people are smart enough to
make the decisions but then you can
start to say wow I thought I was eating
a great way but we just saw that study
that came out that most kids aren't
eating any fruits you know most kids are
56 kids aren't any vegetables like that
may be a long-term problem
for us as a society I think it's pretty
certain to be a long-term problem it
already is a long-term problem that's
right you know it is reaping it right
now when you look at the incidence of
obesity and type 2 diabetes and
pre-diabetes and you know uh uh you know
metabolic health is is kind of a core
piece in your Nutrition chapter like
having metabolic flexibility and all of
that like that's a newer conversation
where there's a lot of emergent science
coming out so I'm super interested in
looking at that and and perhaps that's a
way into talking a little bit about the
wearable technology like you're you've
got a I assume those are that's those
are aura rings that you got on I got the
whoop on
um and that's another piece when it
comes to the Suburban moms or like the
average person
we're we're now in a in a situation
where we have all these data points like
we can look at like oh my sleep stages
and my HRV and my resting heart rate and
my metabolic rate my skin temperature
but it's like what do I do with that
yeah how do I interpret this what is it
what's important about this do I have a
second lesson or not based on that right
and and with you know the kind of
continuous glucose monitors also like
monitoring you know glucose intake and
how to make sense of that I think
there's a lot of risk of people leading
to conclusions with this these data
points and then making poorly informed
decisions about nutrition
Etc because they don't understand the
complexity and the Nuance of what all
these data points are trying to tell
them setting aside also you know just
the the accuracy of all of these things
which I think you know you you can't
rely on you know too too much
no I mean uh you know I'm often wearing
more than one tracking so you know
between the two of us I mean Kelly does
really enjoy this Aura ring but he hates
um wearables and tracking as a general
rule he just he's not into it and I on
the other hand I'm a total nerd and I
love like tracking everything and seeing
everything but I think
um over my own life of having every
single possible wearable and tracking
every possible piece of data for me when
push comes to shove the only one that
really matters and is really actionable
for me is my step count which I
literally could get from like a five
dollar pedometer that was made in this
you already have one on your phone um
and I already have that on my phone
um you know and you know you're exactly
right I mean you know I could be wearing
a Garmin and an aura ring and do a
workout and it would track completely
different calories and you know
different metrics and I would get
different sleep scores and my heart rate
variability would show up as as you know
different on each one so you know I sort
of enjoy uh seeing at a high level you
know how my sleep looks on my aura ring
that's really what I use that for we
recognize people are unique your
tolerances and your history and all the
things going on so you get to we run at
this always is here's what most people
are going to experience
drinking alcohol before you go to bed
typically will impact your sleep so that
doesn't mean we don't drink alcohol that
just means we make it now an informed
decision about alcohol related to sleep
that hey I'm with friends there's an
amazing bottle of wine out I haven't had
a margarita in a long time it's hot or
I'm gonna have a margarita
but I know the trade-off is here and I
think that helps us to make informed
decisions about some of these behaviors
let me tell a story about a friend who
works with whoop kit Courtney I don't
know if you've met Kate yeah yeah I
haven't met her but I know she is we
have the same managers okay so Kate
Courtney is one of the greatest American
mountain bike cyclists ever she's a
world champion she's a superstar and one
of the most complete athletes I've ever
met just really pays attention is
thoughtful about details she's Racing
for the world championship title her
first world championship and she wakes
up and her whoop says
poor recovery and she's like nope it's
wrong she's like a 12 it's red and she's
like she's like no way I'm I am I feel
great I'm gonna win today and so she
just ignores it and she goes off and
wins and then calls up Whoopins like hey
your algorithm's off and they're like
we're not off and and then they were
like you're right we were off and she
got this weird data telling her to
ignore how she felt right and again
instead of taking that piece of
information and saying huh how does this
you know integrate into my behavior my
understanding of how I feel myself and
trusting that because she's done that
and she's so capable that she could have
said oh my my device is telling me not
to race today but here we have such a
incredible athlete who's done an amazing
job of understanding herself controlling
what she can control setting the
parameters to win that she was like oh
that data doesn't make sense with the
whole and I think that's amazing and
simultaneously
we have people who come in with chronic
pain and persistent pain and the first
thing I ask them is how much you're
walking and tell me about your sleep
those are the first two questions about
anything that's going on and you know
one of the things they're like I said
great I'm like great prove it you know
so what gets measured gets managed right
yeah
yeah yeah you know I think you know what
I take from what you just shared and and
what I agree with is that these are
tools and they are powerful tools if you
have the right relationship with them
like you have to look at Trends over
time caught up in individual data points
because you know like maybe the thing
flips up or like you know you don't know
how so it's like and look I love my
whoop I I leave it on and they're a
great sponsor of the show and all of
that and I I get a lot of value in it
and I think on the Sleep piece one thing
I've learned and it was interesting you
talked about this in the book like you
realize that if you if you're trying to
get eight hours of sleep like you better
be in bed for like nine hours I mean
because you're not actually asleep the
whole time that you think yes no I was
actually going to say that when Kelly
was talking I mean that's the other like
key learning that this you know it one
of these tools have given us is that we
really had no idea until we started
tracking that that you know the average
person is losing a whole hour of sleep I
think Matt Walker talks about that in
his book as well but you know between
Matt Walker's book and actually seeing
it in real life realizing that oh okay
going to bed at 10 and waking up at six
is not eight hours of sleep right about
seven hours of sleep that was a big
Revelation for us and and these tools
are what helped us get that so I'm with
you I mean I think there's their tools
and I think if you you know you don't as
long as they're not dictating how you
feel
um which I think actually can happen but
as long as they're not dictating how you
feel and you have a good relationship
with them then they're great and they
also have to fit in you know early on I
became sort of mini obsessed with HRV
that when it was just new and do you
there was uh it's complicated it is and
there was an HRV device can I tell the
story oh please yeah okay so we get like
an early early age this is what it's
like to be married this is probably
2012. like you probably got one of these
I don't even know what company it was
but in order to track his HRV he had to
get up and be up for 15 minutes but then
he had to go back and lay down and put
all these nodes all over his body and
then lay there for 20 minutes this
sounds like a Tim Ferriss thing and um
and meanwhile at this point our kids are
like
you know seven and four and they're
awake and like we're trying to get them
ready for school and make breakfast and
make lunches and I was training for the
Molokai so I was just like I am an elite
middle-aged dad who's gonna slay this I
need this information and I finally
after like four days I was like dude
like this whole thing we're doing in the
morning like you need to be present
we're helping with this kid thing we
have funny and I'd be like you just
ruined it now you have to lay here so no
we got we got in this whole battle about
because you know he had to go and so
obviously that wasn't sustainable and it
you know the technology has gotten so
much better since then but that was
where we started
but what is important to understand
about heart rate variability like I just
all I I know is that okay when it's low
like that's not good and you should
chill out and when it's high like okay
that's you have a good you're winning at
life push it
I think um that's a really great use of
it uh you know I suspect you are a very
durable person and then I could throw a
lot of stress at you and you can swallow
that down and kind of normalize the next
day that would be my guess based on your
back be surprised
you could suffer through
um you know we're not experts at heart
variability it's another piece of the
equation we're trying to understand
inputs and outputs and what where can we
help people understand
why they may not be recovering or
feeling as good even though they feel
like they're doing the thing so you know
one of the things that a statement that
we have is we're like the bigger the
engine the bigger the brakes you need a
really if you're an executive person
you're you know working hard you're an
athlete you're a working single mother
you need to have a set of tools to be
able to hit the the breaks at the end of
the night I think it's like the Moto
people are like either wide open on the
gas or you're on the brakes and the back
wheel is locked up as you're sliding and
I think we're really good at opening the
gas now and if you look at so much of
what happened the last 10 years before
we've kind of gotten into sauna and cold
and down regulation it was all about how
do we wake up and go yeah and then you
get to the end of the day and you don't
know how to calm down you know we this
came to a view when a few years ago we
had a friend who got a blood panel and
it freaked her out because said she was
pre-diabetic
and some of our liver markers were off
and so the first thing we said was well
tell us about your day are you under
stress I mean like we need to know a
little bit about you not just show me
how many macros you counted and she said
well you know I'm under a lot of stress
and we're like how do you cope with that
stress and she said well I usually drink
some wine before bed okay great so tell
us about that you know we're curious and
she's like well it's it's sometimes it's
two bottles of one and that if I just
walked in and was like well you're crazy
no wonder you can't drink two bottles of
wine if I take her only strategy self
coping and not understand that's the
tool she was given and that's what she
discovered on her own then shame on me
I'm a really terrible performance coach
and I think that's where we started to
really understand this this notion of
trying to look at stress and how people
are coping with their stress so they can
hit the brakes in their own home at that
hyper local you don't have to go
somewhere you don't have to hire an
expert you should be able to self-soothe
in the evening and the heart rate
variability is just one of those pieces
I think yeah yeah I think think also one
of the things it
um Kelly and I have really tried to pay
attention to and I think it took turning
40 for us to have the maturity to do
this because we both do thank you lead
through our eyes and suffer and training
but that is you know the question we ask
ourselves a lot is do we have a desire
to train and then we actually try to
listen to that and we try to not be you
know not let our device override that
like you know it's really powerful if
you're someone who uses and moves your
body to actually sort of listen to that
inner do I have a desire to train and
then and then you know and then actually
follow through with that and you know if
we wake up and don't have a desire to
train then that's a day where we just
walk yeah um and we still move it's for
us that's an evolution because we sure
in the old days it was like that's not
yeah yeah I mean we would it didn't
matter it was like six days a week no
matter what maybe you take one day off
and and so you know we have we really
have tried to learn how to listen a
little better and you're you're talking
what's interesting is that that's an
individual as soon as you're on a team
you're on a triathlon team you're in a
soccer team you're going to have to
perform and this is what time practice
is for everybody so you don't have the
luxury of really dialing up and dialing
down and so it becomes even more
incumbent
on us to ask how can we control what we
can control you know when we work we're
working with a division one water polo
team at a local University that's really
good oh Cal shout out they are go Bears
they are incredible sorry please no it
had to come something they uh they are
an incredible coaches a world-class the
women are amazing like I really am
inspired I just volunteer and just get
to be around
and I one of the things I tell those
women is they're not outworking the
competition that model has sailed were
you just like I'll sneak in some extra
volume I'll do a little bit extra
everyone is doing that so what's the
limiter now the limiter for what we
believe is how well you can adapt to the
stress whoever can adapt the best can
handle higher volume and still show up
and be fresher and we've been saying
that forever right whoever does the most
volume is the freshest wins I think
that's like Alan lamb or Pavel or
someone
and so then we can say well that's a
generality now can we apply that to
humans right how can I show up for my
family on the weekends without being
torched or in the evening you know and
not not black out on the couch because
I'm so exhausted how can I adapt to the
stresses in my life whether they're good
or bad and manage that in a way that
leaves me or intact or leaves me to have
more stress and one of the things that
we believe is Believe It or Not people
think they're working really hard
they're not and they can actually work
harder so some of this isn't just
playing defense don't do this because
you'll may get injured we just think
actually you're only working at like 50
percent okay like you can actually go
harder yeah yeah well I I think it's a
very interesting time because this
conversation around recovery
um holding back like trying to calibrate
your output so that you're properly
bouncing back and can be fresh for the
next day is even if you guys have been
talking about it for a long time is
pretty new like you know I'm older than
you guys and I'm a product of that era
where it's just like you just go as hard
and as long and as much as you can until
you just absolutely break yourself like
you know swimming in the 80s it was like
volume I mean we were doing 20 000
meters a day you're going in you're just
there was no like okay today you're
gonna ease off and you're no you just go
in and you go as hard as you can for as
long as you can and I walked around like
a zombie for like a decade and a half
and then you roll the dice on a two-week
taper and and see how it goes and you
know there was no like that's humorous
what you just said by the way is so
bananas oh I mean this was the whole
sport you know and I'm sure there were
other sports that kind of approached
this similarly it was like how much
volume can we actually do just to add to
that really quickly I was a rower at Cal
it's similar and I mean it was 30 hours
a week plus of training but it you know
we would we would train for three hours
in the morning and then like another
four hours in the afternoon soon and
even though the rowing season is spring
we would start doing that on like August
1st I mean it was just like non it was
just like that how was your nutrition
all I ate was Red Vines and bagels
calories it didn't matter what and
um
like the idea like oh you need to be
fresh for the workout what are you
talking about no no one ever talked
about that that was like not part of the
notification like like five hours of
swimming a day for a race that literally
is like 47 seconds long you know and and
you were really good yeah good but like
now I look at the times now and I can't
even relate to this sport like the the
progress is extraordinary and that is
due in no small part I'm sure to the
kind of work that you guys do and
understanding how the body works and the
importance the Primacy of recovery like
allowing your body to repair itself in
between training sessions like what is
that about like literally just being a
zombie for as long as possible and being
in a chronic state of of over training
which really is an injury like that is
an injured and it's a stress body it's a
stress do your job or occupy a role in
the team we call that an injury right
clear mechanism injury there's a bone
sticking out of your arm right there's a
fever or something being a zombie count
zombie I think we're going to add that
in I really that's a really important
piece I can't show up and perform the
way I should perform and It's Tricky You
Know It's Tricky working with young
people you know we have two teenagers
and we are turns out the strictest
parents in the whole you know we're like
you will have to sleep you'll have to
eat these fruits and vegetables you know
I heard you tell a story like what is
what's required in order for somebody to
date your daughter these days have you
updated that like well it's it's
actually worked so we um it's worked to
prevent her from dating yeah basically I
mean um you know just the the Myriad
ways our kids are going to need to be in
therapy in their 20s it started it's
starting to add up I think but um you
know Kelly used to make his own
um like strong manstones who doesn't you
know and I would come into the backyard
on like a Sunday afternoon and there he
is during the concrete and pouring it
into these molds and I was like you are
such a weirdo like I'm even into this
stuff but that's weird yeah and so we've
had two or three of these you know what
do they weigh 150 pounds somewhere some
some are a little heavier I thought you
said 200. I think it might be 200 pounds
and so we have we have the Yannick
stones in our yard
um and Kelly's rule has always been well
when Georgia starts dating someone like
if you know if he if he or she
um wants to date our daughter they need
to be able to lift up this Stone and I
said and my point of view was like no no
you don't want the kid you know you want
like the oversized 17 year old kid with
like all the testosterone dating your
daughter I was like that's actually the
exact opposite the one kid who can lift
that is actually not the kid yeah you
don't you don't want that to date your
daughter but nevertheless our daughter
didn't does have this lovely boyfriend
named Yannick and uh fortunately the kid
loves to train and he can actually pick
up the stones he heard the story finally
heard the story hold it out of the yard
yeah and then one day and then he like
sent me a picture with the stone on his
shoulder yeah so Kelly was so proud you
know I I think what was what's
interesting about that is uh I actually
stole that idea from I think it was Dan
John who said you know it was like this
he had this test of like overhead
squatting or body weight 10 times and as
a test and as you get heavier and
heavier that becomes quite a thing but
just overhead squatting a a barbell is
quite a thing but no one does that
without practicing no one does that
without training and so my my intention
with this is no kid just comes in and
picks up the stone without having some
things built in like this kid trains
this kid loves to play this kid is
interested in you know theoretically was
a screening device and maybe it was a
little blunt but you know the idea is
that they also had that diet that we did
in like 1999 right yeah that's right the
vertical side only protein shakes wasn't
vertical diet it was something else
velocity diet we we briefly followed um
Dan John's because we like to Tinker
Tinkers in Pro this was probably like
two thousand we made it 36 hours and and
the diet is you just eat protein powder
for 30 days
I don't think it was 30 days it was 30
days it was supposed to be 30 days don't
help us all but I mean keep in mind that
this was in the dawn of protein powder
where you know you could only get it in
these you could only get it at GNC and
it was 900. it was like Weight Gainer
900 and I actually was practicing law at
this point so I'm trying to do this for
the and I think we made it 40 48 Hours
how that is so messed up I would like it
if you didn't tell that story anymore
that is so it shows us that like it
makes it okay because it was 2003 body
composition is the reason I think most
people come to nutrition you know if
you're an athlete maybe you come
nutrition because you're like it is a
secret weapon to fuel and do these
things but for most people they initiate
a conversation because it's about body
composition or my cholesterol is so high
I gotta stop eating this yeah crisis or
I mean weight loss when you say body
composition weight loss that's right
let's say weight loss yeah that's right
and uh you know imagine if I'm just like
hey why don't you just eat some protein
powder for 30 days no that's that matter
taste in your mouth it doesn't go away
food yeah food you know I I think that's
really
as we're trying to untangle this
you know we keep flip-flopping back and
forth between
here if you want to win a world
championship this is what we recommend
and we're going to help you find your
blind spots so you can be more durable
and simultaneously because that's that's
our view through this this is what we
talk about with
all the seals and Delta Force and all of
these things and simultaneously we know
what's good for the goose is good for
the gander so how do we scale that
through
that comes from even ideas where
I got to work with really good coaches
Mike bergner is a good example who was
coaching high school kids in the morning
and then he'd go home in his evening and
be coaching Olympians in Olympic lifting
and being there on either side of his
day I could see the through thinking in
his his methodology what was essential
why is he teaching this first skill and
how does that skill progressed to go to
the Olympics
and we should be able to do those things
with these principles that you know this
is the foundation and then you can get
really sharp and pointy as as you need
to to go as far as you want because
really I you know we always talk about
potential and
you know sometimes I think it's easy to
get Doom and Gloom but really you can
feel better and do more in your life if
you take care of the care and feeding of
this this husk yeah I mean the way that
that that I see kind of the value of of
your work in the in the context of of at
least with respect to Elite athletes is
with respect to the best of the best
what's good for the goose isn't always
good for the gander because they're
doing something so specific and you know
they're training really hard and they're
training only specific muscle group all
that kind of stuff ultimately
is potentially at odds with longevity
you know long-term Health like all these
other you know it's like if you're
chasing a performance goal the that goal
is not necessarily in alignment with
long-term health goals or even
relationships right yeah or or
everything else in your life right and
you kind of come in and say well we have
all these other things that will help
you long term be the best Elite athlete
but also are in service of your life as
a civilian down the line
um which I think which is going to
happen yeah which yeah ultimately
despite you thinking you're going to be
like in that Elite State for the rest of
your life you will not I was at
um so so I stranded Stanford in the late
80s and and and my coach skip Kenny
recently passed away and there was a
memorial service for him up in Fresno
where he moved it was his hometown he
moved there after he retired and so a
ton of alumni you know people that I
swam with over the years showed up for
this event and I was standing at the
reception and
and and just off to the side was
Anthony Moss who in my era was the
number two 200 butterflyer in the world
Pablo Morales winningest NCAA swimmer in
history at the time never lost a race at
NCAA championships and Sean Murphy who
is a Canadian backstroker went to the
Olympics incredible uh finalists at the
Olympics and all three of them this was
the era in which the underwater dolphin
kick was being pioneered for the first
time and all three of these guys like
they're they're they're they're their
knees bowed back but were bowing
backwards and they were standing like
you know like they're all standing like
this like my knees hyper extend a little
bit but like Anthony's literally looked
like a bow back that way like like that
right and uh and I'm noticing this and I
and I knew this about them and it's what
made them
those three guys were the best
underwater dolphin kickers in the world
at the time like they could go
underwater faster than anybody and I
went up to Anthony because he had the
most extreme like you know Beau and I'm
like how's your back
and he's like it's terrible i've got
bulge discs I've had to you know I can't
remember I don't think he's had surgery
but he's had chronic problems he can't
do flip turns in the pool anymore and I
was like yeah me too man I'm like
what do you think that's about and so
I'm interested so the reason I bring
that up is
it is that
contrast between like though that that
quality made them extraordinary at that
one thing but here we are we're in our
50s and you know there's chronic brain
pain problems as a result of yeah that's
just the way he stands you know it's
probably the way he's always stood it
made him great at that one thing
um and now is causing him pain so that
that dissonance between you know what
makes you great and Elite at one thing
and how you want to feel later in life
and be stable bulletproof you know
mobile functional and the rest you were
hanging out with Sean Sean Payton who is
now coach at Denver and we were working
with the Saints and he had just gone to
a Hall of Fame Gala and all of the
coaches that he worshiped as his mentors
had to be helped on stage with like
multiple people helping them they were
so crippled and he just said to himself
okay that that can't be me
you want to jump in well yeah we we
actually just were talking to our old
friend Mark Bell who is a world champion
power lifter I don't know if you've
heard of Barkley yeah but he's the
smelly Bell guys
when he was when he won his world
championship he was 330 pounds and sort
of by all conventional metrics like
super unhealthy like he couldn't tie a
shoe and he felt terrible and you know
he probably his blood panel was probably
horrible at that time and he was taking
massive amounts of performance enhancing
drugs and you know it's just like he was
basically not doing well from a health
standpoint but that body allowed him to
win a world championship
um and then you a few years later he got
injured doing a lift and kind of had
this light bulb moment and realized that
that wasn't how he wanted to live his
whole life and he's actually spent the
last 10 years basically trying to like
totally over holiday rewild his body and
his transformation is exceptional
marathons and he's going to run the
Boston Marathon
um but he started did literally by just
walking three times a day for ten
minutes you know he really started small
and and realized he had to take these
real baby steps to sort of you know
figure out how to get back to health and
transform his body and lose all that
weight and gain back some of his
Mobility but I mean you know it's been a
slow process it's taken him 10 years of
baby steps and just adding in you know
adding in different practices as his
body got you know better and more mobile
and healthier and now 10 years later
he's running a marathon next month and
let me apologize to all the athletes in
the 80s who went before in the 90s we
broke a lot of people the model you were
right yeah as long as the clock was
faster and you did it and solved it
there were a lot of eggs that were
broken that didn't need to be broken and
if you could survive because you had the
will and the coach and the support you
maybe came out of that and thrived or
survived and did well enough
one of the things that we like to say is
you should come out of this thing
unharmed even at your Elite it crashes
are going to happen the course there's
going to be you know you may have some
laxity in your shoulders there's some
things like that that are are related
but
it isn't necessarily a given that
because they were able to have a greater
range of motion and Hyper extend their
knees a little bit it's called genuine
recrivatum that doesn't always translate
to low back dysfunction but what we see
is this special skill that gave them
this incredible kick and Big Range
doesn't necessarily they we didn't know
how to control it or support it or take
some of the load out of the low back and
what we did was we just said well as
long we worship the clock instead of
saying is there are there inputs in
there think about the nutrition you know
I mean just PowerBar was just on the
scene I remember hearing like I think
it's Dave Scott talking about like
running with bags of figs yeah bananas
bananas and dates oh my gosh and so if
that's how far we've come you know we do
owe we know what we know because we
broke a lot of people and I want to say
that absolutely you're right that
sometimes there is a cost at being an
elite there is a cost
but not necessarily it's one to one that
that had to be the outcome it was the
only outcome we knew how to deliver at
that time but if you look at you know
what Stanford has done to support its
athletes because we work there they're
really sophisticated about nutrition and
you know and supporting and it looks
like a very I mean you know because you
go back but it's it you're like where am
I is this is Mars yeah it's a completely
different place from when I was there
in a good way
well maybe we can say you can do this
and you don't necessarily have to have
spinal surgery
um right right right so in thinking
about like these these Vital Signs and
and the kind of principles around
mobility and stability Etc
um I want to talk a little bit about
like some of the you know core things
that the listener or somebody who's
who's watching this should be thinking
about incorporating into their daily
routine like I don't want to complicate
people's morning routines of course God
forbid but like you know what are what
are some of the key things that you
think you know move the you know move
the needle the most
that people are not thinking about not
practicing about not you know how about
let's um
let's start with just some getting some
input beginning a conversation with your
body about pain or about making yourself
feel better we think that in our
clinical experiences that if we had
people do a little bit of myofascial
work rolling soft tissue self massage
whatever language you're comfortable
with in the evening before they went to
bed that was a great entree in to
understand your body feeling your blind
spots getting non-threatening input into
the system so if you
in the evening could sit down next to a
ball a tennis ball a softball roller and
ask yourself from the day what store
what hurts what's achy and I'm going to
commit 10 minutes the first part of this
show I'm watching I'm just going to roll
around on whatever
ails me
that's a really important conversation
you could begin to have I'm talking
about 10 minutes like that's super
reasonable and the reason we started
shifting that to the day from the day
and the gym to the evening was that we
saw that people didn't actually do it or
want to do it as a team but in the
evening they had time and agency and
nothing was happening at the end of the
day like you're on Facebook you're you
know you're surfing Instagram so there
was this great moment where you could do
some some self-care and 10 minutes a
night usually turns into 12 to 14
minutes because you discover something
you can sit on your coffee table put
that ball right in your hamstrings just
roll around then the next sort of level
there is we could say hey can you take a
full breath in that position so if
you're working on something or you've
got some aspect of your body that hurts
and you push on it and that takes your
breath away or you catch your breath
then we found an area of Interest it
doesn't mean we need to shy away from
that it's okay that that's uncomfortable
to compression so one of the first
things we can do is say am I doing harm
to myself no not at all you can if you
can take a full breath in and out you're
signaling to your brain this is safe
nerves are king of the breath the breath
is King of the brain that's iang our 101
and why breathing is such an important
part of yoga is teaching your body to
accept and be able to control those
positions by breathing there your brain
says it's not a threat so if you find a
painful spot or a sore spot or an
uncomfortable spot you found a spot and
all you need to do is take a four second
inhale there
contract into the ball roller and hold
that for four seconds we call that an
isometric in the in the parlance right
you're just building a tension or a
movement without Motion in the limb and
then exhale a long time for eight
seconds long exhale and what you'll find
is if you just repeat that cycle a few
times whatever hurts in that area that
you're working sometimes starts to hurt
less you're desensitizing you're
changing your some threat resetting some
threat signals and if you started doing
that on your back your hips your calves
your feet what you realize is wow I can
make myself feel better and because you
did it before your bed it's like getting
a massage you tend to sleep a little bit
you're down regulating yeah and We snuck
in breath practice and you had to get up
and down off the
groundwork you ruined it yeah exactly
right that's exactly right
yeah and I mean I think we talked about
it a little bit earlier but um we are
really such huge fans of people
you know taking using these practices
and thinking about how they can
constrain or change their environment so
they don't have to think about it you
know we have standing desks everywhere
at our office so you can sit we have
stools but the the default is a stand
and so it just makes it not a choice if
you're you know you can't rely on your
willpower that day and you know we have
Mobility tools all over our living room
floor and we have easy ways to sit on
the floor and we have balance boards all
over our house and you know ways to
practice balance and you know I'm sure
you've heard of Chris Hinshaw's old man
balance test uh where you put your shoes
on on one oh this is great everyone
you're welcome everyone listening should
do this test you still call it again
it's called the Chris Hinshaw
um and it's called The Old Man balance
test and he actually created it um so
that he would have something to compete
against his kids and win and so uh the
idea is you put your socks and shoes on
the floor and you stand on one leg and
you reach down and grab your sock and
you put on your sock without putting
that foot down and then you reach down
and grab your shoe and put your shoe on
and tie it and then you switch and do it
on other side and it's a really great
two minute balance practice and that's
how I put my shoes on every single day
you know and that's something
that's just this little you know small
behavior that that we add into our day
that's easy and fun and you can you know
challenge your kids to do it and so you
know that's just one of those things
that we've snuck in and said hey there
are ways that you can change your
environment and just slightly think
about your environment differently so
that these are just things you do
without having to rely on Willpower or
motivation
I think I would struggle with that
everyone struggles with it it's okay
it's hard and that's okay you know keep
in mind that if you just grease that I
mean I don't know where you're living
some kind of barefoot cult that's cool
but you know some of what we're trying
to do is you know is that dynamic
balance work and if you can just start
to think about your environment a little
differently then that's something you
never have to do ever again I don't need
you to work on balance because you did
all this and if you really want to make
it super gnarly put your shoe three feet
away from you you have to do like a you
know a crazy lunge or drinking game to
get it but when you start to shape your
world this way
you know rinse wash repeat for a decade
and let me know how that goes for you
and you you brought it up it's difficult
for us to imagine our futures I think in
economics we always think that the
future is going to be more valuable I
think there's a term and phrase for that
right but in willpower we always think
Kelly started tomorrow is not going to
eat the cookie and he'll start yoga
tomorrow right but that's that future
self is never as valuable as as today
and you'll have more money and more time
yes things that you can you can do today
yeah I think it's also important for
people to you know once you you know
with this old man balance test for
example you know we traveled yesterday
sat on a plane did a lot of driving I
may have had a harder training session
and so you know every single day my
experience is different with it I have
some days where I just grease it and get
my shoe and sock on tie my shoe and I'm
like I am crushing this and then other
days based on you know what's been going
on in my life it's different but it's
all just sort of information I have and
I'm able to say Hey you know I'm
struggling a little bit with my balance
today I'm feeling a little bit stiff you
know maybe I should spend a little time
you know mobilizing my hips today and
make sure I get enough steps in because
I was you know stuck sitting all day
yesterday on a plane it's like you know
it's just information on which we can
make
is a good piece of data it's called the
solak
single standing one leg eyes closed and
you should be able to stand on one leg
remove the visual field that's where the
eyes close and balance for 20 seconds
without touching that's the Benchmark
really easy yeah but it's not you know I
I was just speaking in a big conference
and a a provider from Norway came up and
he said you know what we do is that the
solac is actually too hard for most
people and so what we do is we put them
in front of a wall a white wall so you
can do this with your parents so they
can touch the wall but the white wall
allows them to keep their eyes open but
removes the visual information right
because what happens is as we get older
we stop feeling remember the foot has so
much ref real estate in the brain right
that homunculus sort of sensory motor
cortex part and if you take away the
eyes if you have down regulated how good
your feet are you know how how surfaces
you're on you take away a lot of key
balance visual information he started
doing this because everyone Falls
elderly fall in Norway and snow storms
because it's all white and you don't get
any visual information or in crowds
people fall in crowds because you can't
see where the the ground is and
understand so you know it turns out of
course that we're obsessed with foot
function and being Barefoot and having a
rock solid rad feet makes you better at
surfing and everything else yeah and
it's such a simple thing right that and
not sexy it would be easier
but when we when we started working on
you know there's obviously from our
friends at FMS and it's originally a a
Gary gray idea this why balance test
where you can actually have someone
stand on one leg and then just make a
why you know the the what the first part
of the Y goes out in front of you and
then the two other arms go behind you
and you can just reach out as far as you
can with your foot and take a breath
there and we use it as a dynamic warm-up
I'll hand you a medicine ball and then
I'm like okay how far can you get that
foot out in front of you and suddenly
you realize oh there is time for me to
play more in some of my training if
you're jumping on the trainer I love to
I mean mountain biking is our jam and I
spent a lot of time on the trainer and
during my warm-ups for the trainers when
I do a lot of exploring and playing and
I see something on internet and I'm like
oh that rope looks cool or that's fun I
use it as a as a warm-up device and I
think one of the things we could give to
all the athletes listening and people
like to exercise is incorporate a little
bit more play into your training still
do the training you're still gonna we're
still gonna suffer and do brutal one
minute on pieces or whatever is we're
gonna do but there's a lot of
exploration and it may be as simple as
Juliet and I love to go out and play
Frisbee you know before we go after like
we have double dutch ropes at our office
and actually I don't know the last time
you tried to do double Dutch but it's
really hard it might have been it might
be 50 years at this yeah yeah it was
early 80s I've ever tried and uh
yeah but you know we have double dutch
ropes around and we have balance boards
and we have you know in our garage at
our house we have a pegboard and you
know every single teenager who walks
through our garage B lines directly for
the pegboard and like tries their luck
on the pegboard and so we just try to
have these things around to make it fun
and play and so that it's not just all
like get on the bike and Crush yourself
you know we just try to try to make some
of this fun because you know it is fun
to use your body and be able to use your
body and connect with other people and
you know throw a ball and throw a
frisbee and if there was one thing
though
people love to ask us what's the one
mobilization oh yeah right it's my
favorite thing to watch Kelly's face
when someone asks him this because he
does this I could just do yeah hey Kelly
if I just do one thing like what would
it be you know and and so he his head
like tilts to the side and then he kind
of starts like twitching a little bit
um but he's really asking it was what's
not important right yeah and so I just
peek out from the background and I'm
like the couch
I think today we are not spending enough
time with the hip and extension and if
you go to a yoga class and jump into a
warrior one where you're like wow you're
really into this kind of triangle pose
split stance position and there's a
reason there's so that's so heavily in a
lot of the movements of rehab of sort of
movement practice
it's such an important person that's
position that's the position we walk
around in being able to take my leg
behind me and Sprint and Sprint faster
and if I want to run faster I'm going to
be able to need to have that knee
further and further behind my butt into
a lunge but it's the one thing I think
we're witnessing as modern people
because we do so much sitting and so
much you know work on the computer we're
seeing that people are losing that
capacity to effectively have that leg
behind them and we have a test in there
called the couch stretch test which is a
shocker and to your point earlier
someone said you know hey I can't act
with my glutes one of the things that
happens is that if that interior line so
the line running down the front of your
body your quads the connective tissue
system
you're a hip capsule if you can't bring
that hip effectively behind you like in
a deep lunge and squeeze your butt that
tells us we sort of are being inhibited
by that position and oftentimes what
happens is that we end up in shapes
where we're not very competent we don't
even have the range or we don't have the
exposure there whatever is the limiter
and that can inhibit our ability to
control that and one of the reasons we
see that stiff quads being on a bike
kicking long lever kicking all day long
rectus Morris all the running can make
us really stiff
all of a sudden when we're in the hip
extension or hip extension we can't
squeeze the butt effectively recruit
very effectively we call it positional
inhibition that can contribute to the
loss of glute function controlling the
back so
whether it's knee pain or low back pain
and we have so many stories of us adding
in these movements some lunges some
Bulgarian split squats some isometrics
in these positions and people's backs
get better their knees get better their
butts turn on
that would be the thing I would say yeah
the one thing I'm sorry about the one
thing the one thing plus plus vegetables
well that's like the main antidote for
all the sitting and the sedentary
lifestyle that is like that is the the
low hand the position I think that's the
one thing that like we're all doing too
much of that's contributing to all of
these imbalances and ultimately uh you
know atrophies of certain muscle groups
that lead to our pelvises not being like
you know like all the kind of things
that have those
lower back and knee Downstream you know
injury and when people if you're
listening to this and you're you're like
hey I've got some pain in my body
it can be really daunting to say what's
going on there you know and if I give
you this laundry list of like sleep
nutrition hydration stress breathing
practice you're like whoa whoa okay
that's a lot I gotta work on that but
one of the things you can absolutely
control right away is your range of
motion and oftentimes when you go see a
physician or we're trying to to manage
pain and positions no one really owns
range of motion or position what we end
up seeing is there's all this
conversation about the tissue health or
getting stronger but no one ever checks
your native range of motion and we see
this actually as a feature of a lot of
the very sophisticated training so we've
had the pleasure of working with the
49ers last year and one of the things
there strength conditioning staff has
identified was the rehab staff is
putting out fires and trying to get
return players to the field the strength
staff is trying to develop the
capacities and Physiology let's get you
stronger and fitter but no one really
owned full position so they had athletes
who were coming in who are couldn't
bring their knees up very high or
missing hip extension or ankles and they
didn't have they were realizing that
they weren't really seeing it and then
the rehab staff might put people out
back into play but they're they were
pain-free or healed and now they've got
to do their job and the strength staff
is like didn't get enough so enough time
to develop these positions but as a
mortal person
if I discover that there's some aspect
of my tissue system I have shoulder pain
for example I'm just saying is a I don't
but you get the idea if I can put my arm
over my head that's a really simple
place to start by restoring the function
of your body and you can imagine if
you're swimming and you're ineffective
at putting your arm in your head that's
going to be tricky sure right so when we
can start giving people some simple
Diagnostics some Vital Signs around key
movement features that can be a really
powerful way to untangle what seems like
very complex pain problems yeah I mean
the question that I have as a follow-up
to that is is where does flexibility
come in because when you talk about
range of motion particularly if you're
over indexing on strength work
you're going to reduce your range of
motion not necessarily you shouldn't
well like I just know if like if I'm if
I start throwing heavy weight around
like suddenly like I you know I'm
swinging my arms around my shoulder it
doesn't feel the way it did you know
prior to putting on a little bit more
muscle mass unless I really focus on
making sure that I'm maintaining that uh
and there it is right of flexibility you
can't just say to someone get stronger I
just saw a great coach name France Bosch
talk about if you get hypertrophy on
athletes you just get them big
you can actually really wreck their
coordination you change the penation
that's the how the fibers align you
change angles of pull you change how the
brain is interpreting what's going on
you have to account you can't just say
get stronger otherwise we just give you
blood pressure you know Blood Flow
Restriction cuffs and an assault bike
and we would just get everyone big well
yeah and on the extreme uh spectrum of
that just look at a bodybuilder they
can't like they can barely move they
have that's right yeah yeah like our
friend Mark Bell he literally couldn't
like he had to put a shoe on with a
stick did you watch physical 100 no oh
this great Korean show where they
brought in oh yeah
so fun
ripped up like Korean dude and men and
women who are badass wrestlers skeleton
athletes track field track cyclists we
won't give it away very diverse though I
mean it's like every kind of uh you know
there's some dancers there's a 50 kilo
concrete ball and then there's a test
they call it like the Hercules test or
something Atlas and they had to just
hold it they had a couple strong man and
you had to get it over here to get over
your head over your head and then
there's a jacked bodybuilder in there
you're like you're like what happened
with that guy I mean clearly yeah unless
you have any Insider knowledge and and
that guy couldn't even get the ball over
his head and hold it for one second
everyone else held it for two hours he
couldn't even find a position because
the cost of his aesthetic Drive had
nothing to do with the application of
that and I think one of the things that
you bring a really good point to is our
fetishization of the gym and gym culture
hasn't necessarily always connected to
Mi training for something what's the
minimum dose in the gym so I can be a
better swimmer right right we're like oh
just get bigger and stronger strength is
never a weakness if you can't if it
starts to mess up your swim if you can't
put your arms over your head yeah
then yeah or you just start to cramp up
you could yeah yeah you don't have to
but suddenly you but somewhere in there
you know I think Tyler Hamilton said in
his book would you rather be have your
hematocrit up two points or be two two
pounds louder he's like two pounds later
you know because
strength to weight does make a
difference it that matters so those are
all considerations and if your point is
that I'm doing something we call that
session cost and if that thing is
removing my ability to move freely I
need to either modify it or put in
another stimulus to maintain my range it
doesn't necessarily mean just because I
got a little bit stronger that I have to
change my technique or style but it
could certainly if we're not keeping an
eye on and I think that was why a lot of
athletes were like hey I'm a worse
swimmer when I do this leg press right
yeah yeah you start bulking up and
suddenly you can't you don't have the
flow and the technique and the range of
matter I believe you yeah but the
important distinction here is that
um
Mobility like Mobility work is not the
same as stretching and you make that
point pretty clearly in in the book
there is a distinction between these two
things just because you're stretching
you're not working on your your mobile
not necessarily not necessarily I mean
you could be but you know and and I'll
let Kelly talk about the anatomy part of
this but I mean I think what we learned
in the 80s and 90s and I know I did when
I was a D1 athletic Cal is that nobody
ever really did much stretching because
it didn't work that much right we were
just all passively you know stretching
our tissues Swing Your Arms Around yeah
I was like incredibly flexible and then
when I got back into multi-sport in my
40s there was this idea like oh you
shouldn't stretch if you're a runner and
I kind of bought into that and I've lost
a lot of that flexibility to my
detriment like I wish I had kept that up
and I think that that has been harmful
to me your range of motion doesn't I
want to jump into it your range of
motion doesn't have to change because
you age that's the one physical you're
gonna be less powerful you may be able
to maintain your aerobic power for a
long time we know that that to be true
but your ability to express your range
of motion in your joints doesn't have to
degrade necessarily you may have bombony
blocks and a patina of athleticism
as we take this systems approach you
being able to get up and down off the
ground or flex your knee all the way
doesn't have to go away and I think that
that's important to remember to consider
for people yeah
um
squatting no boy
people that's my weakness they do I
couldn't agree obsessed with dead
lifting and squatting for some reason
you know what's amazing we just made two
new things uh one of them is a a pad
that makes it easier easier to do a
Bulgarian split squat so you can slip
this pattern of a barbell and you can
put your foot up there and it really
does help you get into a lunge
and and it doesn't work people hate it
they don't like to do this movement it
doesn't sell it's like one of our best
ideas we just did another thing that
allows you to do hip thrusts which is
when you lay on a like a bench and you
put a barbell on your hips and it's kind
of a modified squat people love that and
to your point so much more fun to squat
it is not fun to Sprint lunge get into
these split stance positions
but why are these so important like why
did you you know make you know an entire
vital signed chapter on squatting
like why is this so key in your mind you
know really
you're going to lower yourself up and
down
a bunch
so you squat all the time whether you
like it or not and notice in this at
this book we don't talk about squatting
weights we just talk about the ability
to access the squat and the reason that
such a fundamental position is that it
ties in a lot of joints and a lot of
tissue systems all at once so we don't
just look at your ankle or ankle by
itself or knee by itself or hit by
itself we're looking at the coordinating
the system and getting up and down out
of a chair off the toilet all of those
things very important cycling is a bunch
of single leg squats done in that
position so what we can start to ask is
I don't always have to be a bilateral
squat can I do a single leg squat in
that position but when we say squat what
we really mean is I'm in a hinged shape
and my knee is bending towards my chest
that's really the definition of a squat
so to take squatting away means that
you're gonna not be moving in your
environment very well and it's an easy
diagnostic for people to quickly pick up
if they're having these gross motor
restrictions or can't access these
positions I think that's what's that's
amazing and if you want to go in Japan
or toilet in another country or you're
going to find that sitting by the side
of the road waiting for a bus we should
be have access to these positions these
are resting positions and I also you
know there's data to show that people in
those cultures have far fewer Orthopedic
injuries hip replacements low back pain
you know and and sort of a lot of The
Chronic issues and pain problems that we
have you know as Western humans that are
sitting in chairs and have lost the
ability to squat it's malasana and yoga
right it's this deep squat position and
one of the reasons that's so important
is that it's one of the ways where we
can get really good flexion in the
lumbar spine when we sit all the way
down like we're just hanging out whether
your heels are up off the ground or not
your knee comes to your chest you take
that knee in full range of motion you
take that hip into that aspect of full
range of motion and the lumbar spine
reverses is and so it's a restorative
position for so much of the extension
arching forces that are sort of modern
endemic to us it's a way of restoring
and putting in loaded flexion into
people in a really graded position and
that that's my most challenged position
for me of all the tests in this book
that's where I struggle the most and you
know like you said you wish you'd focus
a little bit more I mean my ankle range
of motion is terrible and you know I was
still with terrible range of angle range
of motion able to be a D1 rower at Cal
and go on to win three World
Championships
and you know you're pushing off the wall
in a squat
uh well certainly you are yeah so it
turns out maybe
you know if we had been more effective
we could have shaved More Time by
getting you and training you into
positions be more efficient just to be
clear you don't have to be a huge
squatter I think a squad is a practice
we can goblet squat hold something in
front of you you could just air squat I
think there are better ways and and more
effective ways for most people to train
the system do I need to have my
mother-in-law do heavy back squats no
we've definitely fetishized it because
it's easy to see progress I can put
another kilo on the bar it's easy to
measure you know that I've changed some
capacity but does it make me better at
my sport maybe not so there's an old
saying train the deadlift train the
hinge kettlebell swings good mornings
those kinds of things practice the squat
right but the ability to squat even if
it's just air squat do it without pain
Etc becomes like this proxy for
longevity right like the longer that you
can kind of maintain your ability to do
that give puts you in a position where
you're not going to fall down and break
your hip or you're going to have that
kind of flexibility or your pelvic floor
is going to work better and you're going
to start to expose the connective tissue
systems of your body to the forces that
were there and have been there all along
because you used to toil It On The
Ground I'm not trying to make
romanticize Paleo living I don't like we
watch yeah we watch alone and now we're
like primitive primitive living is not
for me I'm not actually yeah I was I was
really happy to see that like there is a
fetishization of like you know the
ancestral life lifestyle all that and uh
I mean listen you talk about the you
know the dewilding and the rewilding and
all of that like there is wisdom in
trying to be live our lives more in
alignment with certain aspects of how
we've evolved to be Etc but that doesn't
mean we're we need to you know martyr
ourselves no on the contrary yeah yeah I
I you know I first time I ever was sort
of discovered paleo I was like that
makes sense I'm eating more Whole Foods
like that makes sense the old
osteopathic model was done anything
that's white and don't anything that
doesn't rot and I was like well that's
also really good right that pulls out a
lot of things that potentially irritate
to people so I sent this to Julie I was
like what do you think about this this
by the way was in like 2003 so it was
like yeah I remember really I remember
paleo right yeah
I was probably still at my Law Firm I
did a little bit of Google research
whatever you could do back then and the
first paleo recipe that came up was a
recipe for like larva soup or something
and I was like dude Kelly we're not
doing this like I was like this is way
too extreme for us like it's not up our
this whole paleo thing is like you know
I was like but people in the Paleolithic
Era died at age 30. a lot of has changed
in the last 150 years for sure yeah and
what we can say is like
you know there's a definitely a trend in
getting a little bit more light in the
morning people are talking about that
yeah there's one guy responsible we may
have heard yeah
in the morning the um but what we can
start to say is well what are the
biologic processes that that are
required for my body to function well
and a good example is
walking your lymphatic system is the
sewage system of your body so everyone
knows their cardiovascular system you
have you know capillaries are these
veins but your your lymphatic system is
how you move all of the other waste
normal waste from your body so if you've
injured yourself you get swelling all of
that swelling is evacuated through your
lymphatic system your joints are drained
through your lymphatic system the
proteins break down the small the gut
things all of those things get recycled
back into the body through the lymphatic
system
your lymphatic system is built into your
movement system what drives the
lymphatic clearage it turns out it's
pumping of the muscles so if you don't
squeeze your lower limbs you don't
actually decongest and circulate so Andy
Weil talked about was it cross pattern
motion well maybe it was just that we
were moving and in that moving and
breathing we're starting to decongest
and move the waste out and if you've
ever had a sink that's clogged up that
is an example of what's happening when
you sit on an airplane and you get
cankles you're not decongesting which is
why you know doctors are so obsessed
with getting people up out of bed that
you know as soon as they can after
surgery because the only way to really
clear your lymph is to walk around is to
move and keep moving so now we can start
to say well if walking is about drainage
how much how many steps do I need in
order to facilitate that and it turns
out six to eight thousand is pretty good
number to get people moving and again
that's not even about burning calories
that's not about strong feet that's just
about circulation circulation so I think
when when you write when we can push
back on this romanticizing you know
hunting my own chickens in my backyard I
don't need to do that but somehow there
are some things that used to happen to
us we used to sit on the ground a lot we
cooked on the ground we twilled in the
ground we slept on the ground we walked
around there's some things we did that
we probably could do a little more well
we were in in a persistent state of like
low energy movement right like we were
just kind of like moving throughout the
day consistently that's another blue
zones thing as well like
um and and we don't really do that like
even if we in you make this point in the
book like we you may go to the gym and
kill it but then you sit in a chair all
day and like you know that's certainly
nice that's me you know that's a lot of
people yeah and this is not right and
we're not saying that that's not
flushing out you're not right yeah all
of that kind of stuff you know is not
happening so if you're Elite athlete or
someone who trains hard because I think
that the distinguishing between Elite
athlete and someone who trains like that
is is your genetics and what you're
doing with it because as you have seen
people are training really hard and have
gotten really sophisticated about their
training they're training like you know
they're training like the elites whether
they can handle it or not right and one
of the things we know
is if you want to have a better
adaptation to that you need to continue
to decongest and continue to move away
exercise movement that's it yeah and
whatever that looks like to you and
bringing it back to sunlight that's you
know one of the I mean we're obsessed
with walking is I think you know in just
general movement and non-exercise
activity throughout the day but you know
it's also this bonus thing where you get
a little bit of sunlight on your body
you decongest your tissues you you know
accumulate a bunch of non-exercise
activities check this out our daughter
Caroline was a preemie and Juliet had
placenta previa Caroline comes a little
early
we are being discharged from UCSF really
good Hospital supernarly Caroline who is
510 now was her apgar was two she was
very small and purple and uh she's a
monster and they were like okay you're
leaving and Juliet is breastfeeding
she's made this heroic effort to get
milk into our kid and they're like you
just got to give your kidneys vitamins
and I was like look at me yeah Kelly's
like is it breast milk like God's food
like the perfect food what are you
talking about I just know enough as a
physical therapist to be annoying you
know this is UCSF right and I should
they are the and they saved both my
kid and my wife I'm very grateful but so
I asked them
what do you mean I have to give my kid
these vitamins I'm like have you tasted
these vitamins like they're awful and
why do I give my kid these vitamins
she's drinking milk and they were like
well you just really got to do it and I
was like what's the problem and they
said well the problem is women in San
Francisco don't get enough sun or don't
go into the Sun so there's not enough
vitamin D in the milk
and so the child support times so we
could just go into the sun with our baby
and then not have to take these vitamins
and so we you know we just would lay our
little teeny daughter who was like six
pounds at this point we would just lay
her in the Sun for like three minutes a
day and she was fine so they used to get
rid of jaundice in the kids so that's
that's a kind of a case study of of the
fact that we make some of these from no
fault of our own we find ourselves in
environments where we have to now be a
little bit more conscious about some of
these other things yeah
um a sort of analogous uh thing that you
talk about or like a counter-intuitive
sort of thing that I was really happy to
see because I've always agreed with this
but never really uh
was validated for it which is that you
should not put ice on an injury right
like no like it's always struck me as
wrong like
it's like oh you got to get the
inflammation down it's like it's
inflamed for a reason your body is
sending all of it where did you feel
like who told you that like that's how
that's crazy I have to tell I have to
tell the backstory here so I think this
was back in 2011 maybe we were at the
CrossFit Games and uh we met up with a
guy Gary reinel who wrote the book iced
and he was really the first person to uh
in my world in our world anyway to take
this different perspective on icing and
at that time though the guy who had had
created rice had already he had already
um you know turned the corner and said
that that's right compression that was
terrible advice
um so you know there was starting to be
this Groundswell of people talking about
how icing injuries was not the way to go
and we put up this one hour long video
on YouTube
um where Kelly Kelly was interviewing
Gary reinel about icing injuries and
that thing got well first of all this
was in the dawn of time and we were on
Pro so we put the video on YouTube and
the title of it was like I AMG
underscore 447 and we just put it out
you know you know it was the olden days
and we put it out and it this thing
worthy of the Appropriations and
thousands of views but I mean there's
been a couple things we put out into the
world that have generated a lot of hate
and skepticism and I think that icing
video was probably top of the list
because it was so shocking to people I
mean it's just default if a kid injures
themselves you make a nice bag you know
it's just this it was so part of our
understanding of how to manage an injury
in the short term the people were like
really bothered by this advice and you
know slowly but surely I think people
you know the words been getting out that
icing injuries is not the way that you
actually you know you wanna hold plunge
community and people are realizing maybe
we need to put that that cold a little
bit further away from training stimulus
yeah yeah that's not even the same thing
as icing something the reason you train
is to create the stimulus and an
adaptation and if you are robbing your
body of that adaptation by getting in
the cold then you've just undercut the
purpose of the training itself and I I
believe in space I think it's great but
I think you have to be conscious about
the timing when the purpose and all of
that and listen if it's half time at the
Super Bowl and you blow your knee out
and you got to get back in the game put
some mice on it and you know you you
want to reduce that inflammation reduce
the pain so you can go if there's an
immediacy to the thing but if you're
trying to heal yourself you want heat
you want to get blood flow in there you
want to get your immune system sending
what it needs to be sending to that area
to repair it as quickly as possible yeah
and you're right it can be a short-term
pain reliever but it's not a great
long-term strategy if your kid gets a
bee sting give her a yeah and if you cut
off your finger you should put it in ice
that's also another house where did you
find it where did you figure that out
because that is really so Progressive it
just seemed it just seemed obvious to me
but it seems it was so contrarian like I
don't know I never really talked
but I I've always preferred putting heat
on any kind of injury over ice for that
reason the head athletic trainers in
Major League Baseball now
basically say we don't ice anymore and
if you're doing that you can't keep up
with you know how we're managing these
soft tissue injuries and really what
what you can see is well is the body so
sophisticated that we're going to
modulate this process of angineogenesis
and remodeling tissues with by getting
it cold and and for everyone who's out
there isn't into the cold physiology
when you have an injury your body sends
out a whole bunch of chemical signals to
the rest of your body and these
circulating cells local stem cells
circulating stem cells come and repair
that the macrophages they gobble up the
tissue and what can happen when you get
something cold as you cut that
connection right you're suppressed
prostaglandin release that's the same
reason we say now we're like oh
ibuprofen maybe let's not use ibuprofen
because it may do the same
you know healing limiting problem you're
going to go on but on the other side of
that coin you know if you have to go out
there and perform as an athlete and you
need to take a couple of ibuprofen
because that's how you're going to make
it through your game you're a pro yeah
then that's fine I mean you know we're
not anti-using anti-inflammatory in in
the right context but but you know it's
but I will say that you know even though
there's been a conversation about this
icing thing for well over 10 years maybe
15 years at this point I mean still it's
the default though for most of the
people we know who have an ACL tear or
you know any kind of orthopedic surgery
for the recommendation from The
Physician to send them home to ice or
get a game ready
um so I mean you know we're making
little baby steps and trying to get that
word out but it's still you know people
really still you feel like you're doing
something right away you know I think
that's what it is yeah and until like so
many other behaviors until we give
someone else something else to do we're
going to default to the thing that makes
me feel like I've done something you
know I I I took this you know this pill
that has micronutrients in it that must
be good enough office eating a salad or
vegetables right or fruits and and yes
that's better than nothing but in this
situation it just turns out now we were
incomplete in our thinking and we
reserved the right to evolve our
positions and here's one where we think
we weren't as effective as we were and
and the proof is we're returning to
people to play at higher levels of
function faster because now people are
healing at the rates of human beings
they were not we're not delaying that or
retarding that healing process we're
just saying hey there's no such thing as
a fast healer you're going to heal it
your genetic limit let's at least get
you to that limit right and not
unnecessarily slow it down I mean it
seems to me to be
a conversation around the difference
between a chronic you know talking about
inflammation is it a chronic
inflammation or is it an acute
inflammation if you have an injury you
have an acute inflammation you need to
like you know figure out how to address
that chronic inflammation that's a
different protocol and a different set
of problems that need to be looked at
yeah that's right that's right and it's
okay to become more nuanced and not just
attack everything with the same Hammer I
think that's absolutely okay and and
even if we just you know sometimes
people get a little confused on this and
we love getting cold we think it's
really fun and maybe that's just the
best part of it it's super fun that we
feel better and wait for this everyone
all you touchy-feely day to people
athletes that feel better tend to
perform better people that feel better
in their lives tend to be more stoked
and do better so if icing getting in a
coal plunge excuse me makes you feel
better I'm down with it could be range
of motion for your vasculature it could
just be well there's hormonal and sure
what I'm saying is there's so many
aspects of monkeying with being
uncomfortable you know Laird says Lord
Hamilton says Hey heating up and cooling
down are the two most expensive
processes your body engages with let's
become more efficient at that well that
seems reasonable have you ever done heat
training for Iron Man well no I know but
I know like people who train for bad
water put treadmills in saunas and
things like that so we we know we can
adapt to these things a little bit yeah
I mean our friend Michael Easter wrote a
great book called The Comfort crisis and
you know one of his main points is that
we've you know in our modern world we no
longer feel any discomfort and one of
the easiest ways to do that is to get
hot and cold and so you know that's one
of the 10 000 reasons we love those two
things but you know now I think the
other side benefit of you know our own
heat and cold practice is for us and
this may be you know what's been the
greatest part of us for us is that it's
a chance for us to connect together and
then also we use it as a community
building it's a social thing we've had
some of the best connections and
conversations with our friends and
community and people who come over for
dinner in the sauna that we've had in
the last 10 years and I mean so there
are a myriad of well-studied health
benefits at this point to saunting and
definitely emerging in terms of cold
plunging but you know if I could look
back and say the greatest thing that you
know Asana has done for us is just
connection yeah uh Gabby and Laird call
though sauna the truth Barrel yes and
then Neil and Neil Strauss and and Gabby
had a podcast called the truth Barrel
where they would get someone in the
sauna to have a conversation I think
even I think Tim Ferriss was the first
one to do that when he had a he did Rick
he had Rick Rubin in his in his sauna
for a podcast conversation oh my gosh
well yeah the Heat
but you have your own uh sauna Cole
plunge protocol in the book I I can't
remember exactly but I think it's three
minutes in the cold and then kind of go
back think of it this way we think
we again we're privy to a lot of tech
and a lot of ideas but we think that the
functional unit of measurement is the
household it's you and your roommates
you and your partners you and your kids
and family and that's where the real
change happens and that concept of
hyperlocality of really understanding
what's going on in the context of
someone's life that's how we make the
big change so we can come in with these
big principles But ultimately it's you
and I need to understand you know where
you're going to put this in and what
your resources are
and anytime we can move something into
the household like a shower that gets
hot and cold or massage or some kind of
thing where you don't have to go out we
see that adherence goes up we see that
compliance goes up and it becomes
manageable we and especially in those
people who are working really hard I
want you to have your Castle set up to
the extent that you can so that you
don't have to make another decision or
go to the place and if if it's easy for
you to step out and get hot cool you'll
do it and if it's if you have to walk
across the street the chance of you
doing Drop to zero right uh which which
beautifully segues and the next thing I
wanted to ask you about selfishly which
is I'm in the process of building a home
gym right now we're in we got like a
40-foot shipping container that we're
customizing with a deck out front stuff
like that so
it's going to take a couple months we're
in the middle of the build right now and
I haven't acquired any kind of equipment
for it yet so obviously you two are the
best people to ask like what this is
what are the things that I should get
what should I avoid like so 40 foot it
it's big it's pretty big oh yeah but
it's not like unlimited space like I
gotta be I have a you know I have like a
indoor bike trainer and I've got it a
hydro rowing machine great um so I have
those two things but then what kind of
weight equipment should I be getting
what should I be looking at what are the
essentials quick backstory did you know
our first gym was a shipping container
no I didn't know that so we actually
started San Francisco CrossFit in 2005
uh and because real estate was so
expensive in San Francisco and Crossfit
was so emergent and we actually weren't
starting it to be a business we were
just starting it because we were like
hey this CrossFit thing is fun and yeah
you know and I was Kelly had a full-time
physical therapy job I had a big firm
Law Firm job so this was a complete side
hustle for us and so we actually had the
idea to get a shipping container and put
all of our equipment inside the shipping
container and then we got this awning
um it was like a Ani is awning the right
way this canopy and you could say tent
if you're disrespecting we were outside
our entire gym was outside for seven
years from 2005 to 2012 and our members
you know we had 350 members and our
members would come and work out outside
in the rain or shine and eventually we
moved inside into a cool building in the
Presidio but we've we've been laughing
during the pandemic because everyone's
like look at this thing I'm doing
outdoor gym and we were like hey we were
the first like we invented the outdoor
gym and and we saw all the positives and
negatives of having an outdoor gym
um when there's any kind of weather but
um I would say that the main thing that
people
sort of think is my gym at home needs to
look like a college strength Edition
platform I need all the likes think
about the old school the programs at
Stanford you walk in there and you're
like whoa this is an impressive gym
maybe you need a squat rack maybe
because that's convenient but those
could be squat stands so really I think
yeah it comes back to you have a couple
monostructural pieces of cardio
equipment which you love that you're
going to do because it's easy to get
intervals in when you're compressed for
time otherwise go out
right dumbbells kettlebells maybe one
barbell for pressing overhead I think
overhead pre you know we could come into
and this and say well what are the
fundamental positions and shapes we
should train especially as a person
who's not 20s trying to win World
Championships anymore
you know I am a huge fan of dead lifting
with a hex bar right a trap bar deadlift
because we can really get control and we
can put the tissues into good shapes but
it really is a lot simpler having
medicine balls having yeah things to
pick up and carry those where I put all
my energy like I am not I I have such a
bad risk from paddling all those years
and uh and broken that I can't handle a
regular barbell anymore I have to use a
sort of a neutral grip but I can handle
all the sandbags and really how do we
make you durable in a short amount of
time when you're what's the minimum
effective play dose so that you can go
out and do what you want to do and then
what is it your family likes to do
what's their input and leaving it as
open as possible is the game because it
is easy to be like oh this is so fun
what a you know let me go to Rogan
I mean there's a couple things I would
add sounds like you have a bike but I
would really recommend getting an
assault bike or some kind of um you know
bike arms if you don't I have and and
there's two reasons for that number one
because it seems like you do like to go
hard in the paint you really can go hard
in the paint on an assault bike but
number two in the event that anyone in
your household ever faces an injury or a
surgery
that is the S like the single piece of
equipment we recommend people get who
have because you can do it with three
limbs yeah no impact no impact so if you
the amount of people that we've put on
with a cast a knee surgery a brace on
that thing and done three limb biking is
all the people and in fact in all of our
surgery recovery protocols that's the
one piece of equipment we recommend
everybody get because you know just for
your psychological Health you know
getting injured and going through a
surgery and not being able to move your
body and that's like the first thing you
can always do is three limbed anything
on that bike so to me that's like one of
the greatest Investments you can have if
you can invest in a gym and and what I
would say is as you are an experienced
mover you have this ability to go out in
the world and and do those things I want
you to spend your tissue tolerance
credits on actual Sports
so do I care that you can full snatch no
I don't but I care that you can muscle
snatch a dumbbell right and from a hang
position and what we'll see is that a
lot of the training decisions I think
make sense for people like my age I'm 50
this year is I want High physiology low
skill where I can get all the bang for
the buck and then go stand up paddle or
go ride my mountain bike or spend my you
know my achilles credits running the
hills instead of smoking myself with
exercises right yeah that's certainly
yeah that's certainly my you know High
physiology I'm not trying to like yeah
completely wreck myself I just want to
be sturdy stable mobile flexible
functional painful so I can go and do
all the other things that I enjoy and
you know basically work on maintaining
that to the best of my ability for as
long as possible I think you could do
your entire I mean you could get a
barbell if that's something that you if
you like to do barbell work but I think
you could get all the stimulus you want
with some dumbbells kettlebells a couple
of heavy balls a few sandbags I mean the
the amount of things that you can do
with just those things are infinite and
and you know to me you can get so much
bang for your buck with that so I mean
if you if you like to do barbell
training then I would get a squat rack
and a couple you know right a couple
pounds of weight don't go crazy those
things but recently one of our friends
was like they're building their gym out
they're like what do you think of this
I'm like I'm not sure you need a
competition bench like that seems a
little excessive like you know you can
floor press just fine but if you just
have a rack where you can and a and a a
bench or whatever where you can do all
the great all the multiple things and
they swing out and you can get them so
they they tuck away and then it's a
pull-up bar too you know you can make
your rack of Polo Bar so that's a bonus
on that subject of like making you know
movement a priority in the home the
obvious kind of next thing that I want
to talk to you guys about is you know
parenting and how you instill a passion
for movement and in in in young people
right like it reminds me of of Peter
attia talking about
watching his kids when they were young
and realizing that kids are naturally
Geniuses of movement like they're able
to do things that now you know we wish
we could do so we are all built to move
the title of your book right and
children know exactly what to do and
somewhere along the line we lose that
that that touch that connectivity that
capacity to move like a Supple Leopard
right so like how do you guys think
about this and practice it in your own
home and talk about it with respect to
young people
I think the the way we've approached
parenting in every respect is is trying
to sort of do as we do not do as we say
and so we've always had a home gym and I
think that that is such an important
part of teaching our kids how much we
love movement and how much we value
movement and you know there's and I also
have a group of ladies who comes over
and works out at my house three or four
times a week and and you know as we said
we have pegboards and pull-up bars and
balance boards and you know double under
or double dutch ropes around you want to
sell a lot of traps for your kids yeah
we want to we've just tried to set a lot
of traps and and show them that you know
movement is a priority for us one of the
things I've seen in now that I'm in my
late 40s is that the the friends of mine
who didn't grow up moving in some way
are the ones that have really struggled
to figure out how to fit exercise into
their life now as adults
um and so one of the things I really
wanted and was sort of intentional about
and I think both of us were was that I
was like when my my daughters leave the
home I want them to
want to move on their own to be
motivated on their own to keep moving
their body because they've learned how
much better they feel if they just keep
moving and you know we like to tell a
story way back when our daughter Georgia
was like nine we had occasion to do all
this genetic testing on the whole family
we did all this genetic testing on all
sorry kids and I know and uh it turned
out that Georgia is had a low genetic
drive to move our daughter Georgia and
Georgia does a genetic marker for
there's a genetic marker on desire to
move wow and so Georgia has a low
genetic drive to move and it that's
actually obvious she loves to bake and
left her own devices she probably would
bake she even created a subscription
because she has a subscription cookie
company and
um and but what we so when we got that
piece of information we realized hey
this is a kid who might be need to be
pushed a little bit more to move because
she's not just she's not going to
naturally get off the couch and start
moving and so we definitely made sure
that you know she was involved in some
kind of sport or activity I think the
other key thing we did is that we made
movement our kids will love to choose
what type of movement they wanted to do
but not whether or not to do movement
and you know that's one of the ways I
think we've found ourselves to be like
the strictest parents like we give ours
our kids choice but it's within these
very clear sort of parameters and that
movement was one of them movement was
not whether or not they moved was not a
choice and how they wanted to move sky's
the limit we wanted to give our kids the
opportunity to try anything they wanted
because I'm really a true believer that
if you find a type of movement that you
like and enjoy and that's fun for you
then you will do it and probably for
your entire life and so my goal was to
let see my daughter Georgia go off to
college which she's going to do this
year and know that on her own accord
without any outside motivation she was
she was going to know that if she kept
moving that she would feel better and do
better in school and have better more
connected relationships and feel good in
her body and be able to do things she
wants to do and it's so interesting to
see that you know we didn't really see
that click individually for her until
about two years ago when she was 15 or
16. and now the kid who when she was
younger would bake and then go sit on
the sit on the couch and watch movies
now bakes and then goes out to our home
gym and deadlifts so what was the I'm
interested in how that tipped from one
to the other because I you know similar
situation some some not frustrations but
you know queries or challenges around
like how to instill or Inspire movement
in young teenagers that aren't
interested in listening to their parents
or yes an expert is someone who lives a
mile away yeah yeah and I'm doing it's
not like I'm not the exam you know right
now
is doing it in her own way like we are
modeling that and yet it's not connected
it's not connecting necessarily I think
one of the solutions is when our
daughters are exercising with their
friends they're in a environment where
there's a team doing it that reduces a
lot of the drag
you know I'm like let's go front Squad
and do Sprints you know and my
daughter's like that's so boring but you
know it lights me up you know I have
this insane desire to move you know
gamifying it putting in a class setting
those are the ways when we have you know
you two at this end of the table
um have you know you can be live a life
of austerity and put in the work and
grind for its own satisfaction but
that's not a lot of the reason that
especially young people love sure to do
it they like to relate yes it's very
cool that Georgia now can go back Squad
and she's in as an aside she's in a
little bit of a power struggle with our
school right now who has a great weight
room because the coach there wants her
to do this foundation's work and she's
like no no I don't need to do that
foundation's work I just want to come in
and squat do you know who my parents are
didn't I get a pass on yeah she really
wants to get a passport she's like what
I need to do power snatch like what do
you need Anton is not giving her a pass
Anton this is for you so you know one of
the things I I've learned that's the
best I've learned working with this
Women's Water Polo team
is that the women like to do things
together differently than boys or men
I'll do it on my own right you know and
so thinking differently about that
solution
putting our daughters into environments
with their friends that really made a
big difference right and creating a
social structure around it really made a
big difference and I I would say also
you know what are we talking about do
your how fit do your 14 year old need to
be when we talk about shaping the
environment one of the things that
Juliet and I figured out early on when
our kids were in elementary school was
we created a walking School Bus
and we realized that we lived within a
mile and a half of the school and we can
set we we do this thing where I'd work
the drop-off Lane and if you've ever had
a kid you work the drop off Lane it's
like the most depressing place on Earth
open the door you hear the the hate and
the stress of each family Royals out and
then you absorb I love you I love you I
love you you absorb it as the parent
volunteer that's opened the door and
it's like the worst experience the worst
so what I said was maybe we don't have
to do that ever again we could just walk
Julius created this walking school bus
but that was a great example of making
it so that we all walked as a family and
that wasn't one more thing we had to do
like at the end of the day your dad's
trumping in being like let's go exercise
you know like that was I made my kids
cry a lot yeah like teaching them to
Olympic left yeah like quick Side Story
um I said you know Kelly's been really
worried our whole kid's life about being
like that dead at sporting events and so
but but the problem is the in my view
the pendulum swung too far and at one
point when I said to Kelly I was like
Hey so our kids should at least get some
benefit from the fact that they're Kelly
starrette's kids like like you don't
ever coach them or because he's so
worried about being that Dad and so I
said so I was like you've got to start
weightlifting with our daughter Caroline
like you've got to start weightlifting
and of course she was very resistant to
it not excited and there were three
occasions where she came in from the
side yard and was crying and she was
coaching the world that was mean and so
look at your foot pressure kid so anyway
that's when I realized we needed to
Outsource and so we actually started
sending her to this Olympic lifting club
and she on her own in with a group of
other kids actually really learned how
to like weightlifting and learned the
fundamental skills with these great
coaches and you know we took ourselves
out of the equation there and so you
know we're definitely fans of
Outsourcing yeah it's interesting how
that works like they just it can't be
the parent it can't be the parent you
can't and like I'm thinking of I had Joe
to send on here and he's talking about
his parents this dude is insane like oh
my we just had him on our podcast up at
four in the morning and yeah you know oh
my God it shows up a mountain before
they can open up their Christmas
Twitter's office is closed the quitter's
office did you tell you about the
quitter's office uh no but I can imagine
I think one of the things that you know
my my daughters were gifted because
their mother is a world champion and a
sufferer and you get your mitochondria
from your mom so children you're welcome
three-time world champion Superstar
we as a family like to go into the woods
in Wilderness we love to run rivers and
be active outside and pulling our kids
into that forces us to do those things
and so you know we making your kids
uncomfortable because you do this as a
family is a really great way to do it
and if you if for some families who are
saying Hey I want to struggle or I
struggle with this let's go for a walk
after dinner for 10 minutes that's what
our family does and it could be a simple
beginning a conversation of doing that
together again I think we're going to
have to culturally have to wrap our
heads around what is it to be a human
being in a member of society
you know how do we do a better job
supporting coaches how do we put PE back
and it's a big multi-layer problem what
you can do is start to control some of
this and home just through activity and
theoretically again give your kids all
the opportunities to do as many
different sports and as diverse
experiences and then when they start to
get older you can specialize and I just
want to make very clear we have met a
massive amount of resistance You Are Not
Alone
um and it for in George's case it did
seem like it was more of a maturity
thing like she turned you know 16 plus
17 and that was when she liked being
jacked yeah there was kind of a a shift
I think she saw the difference in her
body composition if she exercised like I
think she probably had some external
motivation from from just like wanting
to look a certain way she had the
hardest shot in the like the league on
water polo and people were like where
did she learn to throw her I'm like
muscle snatch but I mean getting our 14
year old daughter who probably will be a
division one water polo goalie
um who is extremely athletic and a
gifted athlete but I mean getting her to
like leave Tick Tock in her bedroom is a
serious challenge right so what we
started doing recently is in between all
the training we just do little micro
sessions we just keep it's like 20
minutes we're just gonna do one movement
that's gonna be enough really the idea
of never do nothing like there's always
things you can do in your house together
and Caroline who is crazy and awesome
she was like hey
can we throw knives out here too and I
was like you bet so front squats and
knives she loves the throne set up right
in our side yard so now she's like hey
you know I fetch the knives I'm like you
want to go throw a knife she's like yeah
I'm like why don't we press in between I
think that's really reasonable so making
about music making it the most enjoyable
experience possible you know anytime
you're doing any sport activity with
your kids I mean we used to with
Caroline we'd go hiking we love to hike
and we we invented these things called
emo bears and they're gummy bears and
when our daughters started getting emo
and all Gummy I'd whip out the emo bear
and she'd be back I was like hey how
about a couple of gummy bears so you
know I think you have to do high
manipulation to learn to like to
exercise and train and be in that
training environment that's a learned
and I do think keeping it playful and
fun I mean we went through like a Kelly
will get mad that I describe it this way
but like a bow and arrow phase
we went through a bow and arrow phase so
we have all these targets at our house
and you know so kids can go in the
backyard and do that and you know we
just anything that they're willing to do
that seems fun to them like we're game
like we're in you know if they want some
cool device we're like yes we're in you
know the other thing and this is you
know the most inaccessible sport for
most people but I mean one of the most
fun things we've done with our kids is
ski
um because you know nobody's on their
phones you're on the chair lift you have
this a ton of time to connect we're
outside
um so we've had a ton of fun doing that
with our kids too
um but it's starting to very
inaccessible but I think you don't ever
get to take your foot off the gas I
think that's really and and if we if we
use this algorithm we've been talking
about like scaling from you know
children all the way up to the Olympics
think about how hard it is for adults to
develop the practice and love to suffer
and be uncomfortable it takes a minute
to do that and to change those behaviors
so users have to put it in front of your
kids and micro doses for decade plus
that's how long long it's going to take
I think yeah and our our dear friend TJ
gave us this um he he told us this story
and his kids were in high school all the
time and our kids were in middle school
but he said you know one of the things
he'd notice with parenting is that if
you think of parenting like a marathon
he noticed that a lot of parents stopped
running the marathon at like mile 24
when they're like their kids are like 15
like they sort of give up pulled a
hamstring and you go on without me yeah
the foot comes off the gas because it's
pretty much baked yeah they're pretty
much baked they're pretty independent
you know and his point of view was like
well actually that's when you need to
put your foot on the gas like that's
when they're the most mature the most
you know most able to you know absorb
information they actually they pretend
like they don't but they need the most
support you know and then that's
actually the time to sort of put your
foot on the gas as far as parenting and
so that really had an impact on us and
so I think we've been trying to you know
make sure in our own way that you know
we're we're gonna run across the finish
line of the marathon and really be
present and kind of stay on them when
they're in high school George is a
senior she's looking at last year's
looking at colleges
and doesn't want to play in college
understands and recognize the Collegiate
Athletics is professional Athletics and
just like that's not for me and but one
of the things she graded every
University checked on was the weight
room and training facilities and I was
like it's perfect and she was super
bummed that sometimes she's like Daddy's
girl yeah Kelly was so proud like we had
these like we went we went on this
Midwestern tour and she created these
spreadsheets and it was like you know
overall campus feel gym and she actually
really loved the University of Indiana
and it's like one of the most beautiful
campuses I've ever seen it's like
Hogwarts and we went into the gym and
she's like nope
and she you know she said and and the
other thing she noticed is she said
there's no women in the in the weight
room at this College gym in Indiana
she's like I'm out
so Olympic lifting and powerlifting were
the original amateur sports because they
really could with just a York barbell
set you could train yourself in your
basement and if we can get back to some
of those basic competencies and exposure
of kids to these things you don't have
to be a weightlifter but I want you to
be able to be comfortable with that well
on that subject
I'm sure you've put quite a bit of
thought into how you would revamp uh you
know PE physical education in in the
school system like it's a disaster you
know when I grew up it was the
president's physical fitness test and
dodgeball and what have you but in terms
of something that needs an upgrade I
mean this is certainly you know primed
for that given the fact that childhood
obesity rates are through the roof and
through devices Etc you know young
people are more sedentary and and less
engaged with physical activity than
perhaps they have ever been so like we
need to solve this problem and I don't
think we maybe you both have like such
genetic drives to move and cope but you
know if you'd given me all this Tech I'm
sure bucketed rich and I into this like
suffer lawyer category I know exactly
he's just like he's just put us over
here in this like suffer lawyer we're
over here yeah we're just one unit
you're like we're just one unit and then
mind we represent like one thing yeah
it's okay multi-dimensional suffer yes
um
what you really just brought up are sort
of two things one is how can we
reconfigure
what we're doing during the school day
where kids are mandated to be there it's
a government activity what does that
look like so we can get more movement in
right and and that may mean we need to
give kids three meals a day there or
they can take a snack home they can have
access to good food there for the first
time of course that's tricky
you know if we just started something
like the daily mile which they started
in the UK because kids have to walk a
mile a day right just during that time
who what what teacher can't administer a
walking mile every kid has to walk a
mile we started the first our kids went
to we did a Google talk in 2010 about
looking at the workforce
and then we realized that we were not
applying our lessons to our children and
we went into our local elementary school
and said what do you think about this
radical idea of creating a different
kind of classroom where kids could move
more they could stand they could fidget
they could sit on the ground we could
give them more movement choice and our
principal was like yes let's do it and
then in the next course of a year we
flipped the entire School became the
first all-moving school in the world so
kids had all this agency and choice and
the desk was individually hided for them
so we didn't have to program in a
specific program we just made it so
there was more movement in the day and
so there's that one piece of what
happens if you couldn't drop your kid
off you know or you had to drop your kid
off to a walking place or something like
that how can you how could you get more
movement in because I think we need to
do that yeah and then simultaneously
redefining PE is not this horror show of
you know the flexed arm hang tests where
we do you know kids who don't move or
don't have any families that move how
can we start to use that time to explore
Dance Yoga
bought weightlifting how and what
movements do we think that every child
should know how to do in order to
progress what movement skills and so it
becomes a skill base just like reading
or math or anything else we could do the
same thing with with that and there's a
real opportunity for that I think
there's a real hunger and awareness
because I think parents are like holy
crap we're behind no child no parent
wants their child to be unhealthy and
you know I do think there's a lot of
separate from PE things that could be
done I mean one of the things that
drives me insane and I went to like 500
PTA meetings and now my kids are in
elementary school but our elementary
school was set up so that on rainy days
the kids would stay inside at recess and
watch movies and I was like that is the
craziest thing I've ever heard like I
mean I grew up in a snowy climate and we
actually would put on our snow gear and
go outside and play
um so the notion that kids have to sit
inside and watch movies when it's
raining and that it's you know they're
not going to get a cold they're not
going to get sick and kids actually love
to play outside in the rain
um so that that was a battle I tried to
fight and lost but I mean to me that's
just one of those simple things that
it's like kids can go outside in cold
weather and kids can go outside in the
rain and they need to they need to move
their bodies and they need to play the
other thing is that something like 90
percent of kids live within a mile and a
half of their own elementary school and
you know when we were kids it was like
75 percent of kids biked or walked to
school and now it's like 15 you know we
just had this huge drop you know schools
have rebuilt themselves around the whole
concept of the drop-off Lane that we
talked about before and so I mean yes
the PE programs need to be massively
revamped but I also think there's all
this sort of connected stuff how do we
make sure kids can move more in the
classroom how do we build in things like
the daily mile how do we make sure
little kids are getting all the time
they need to play outside at school how
do we facilitate environments where kids
can walk on bike to school safely and I
think even that would make a huge
difference because you know tackling the
specific PE problem is such a huge one
it makes me feel tired to think about it
um but I mean you don't agree you don't
have to solve the problem for those
School District you have to solve the
problem for your classroom so you have a
child in a classroom you can improve
that classroom the teacher is the
functional unit of that and there's all
of those things and if your teacher can
teach math and skills and social studies
they can teach squatting and there are
tons of resources available
what we're going to have to do is think
differently about the problem because
clearly who owns this that's that's
issue no one wants to own it yeah well
it's a it's it's a Grassroots problem in
the classroom with the teacher and the
the students in that particular
classroom and it's a federal that's
right you know program issue that scales
all the way up to the White House so the
question is is there political will for
this like I remember when
you know Michelle Obama was the first
lady and there was initiatives around
moving and like eating healthy and you
know that did not go well and it's like
insane do you remember Jamie Oliver was
like run out of the country and it's
pizza that's like how dare anybody come
in and try to like improve you know the
Health and Welfare of of young people
like I think the last time
physical fitness in the public school
system was a thing was when Arnold
Schwarzenegger was talking about it
right like I don't know what the current
state of it is now but I know it's
decrepit in comparison to what it could
be and there's certainly a need but
there's so much bureaucratic red tape
all you can do is like you said Kelly is
get involved in you know your kids
classroom and try to begin there there
is a the other thing is to say okay this
High School Middle School elementary
school problem is beyond my skill but
then there is this thing this kind of
irregular Army of of Youth Sports so the
youth sport coach becomes even more
important because this may be the only
time where kids learn to move and play
it's a good point and we actually the
data is pretty good that a lot of kids
actually do engage in small Sports it's
not everywhere and it's not equal for
sure but the data is that kids are
starting to play so that we now can
think well how can we support the
coaches because that may be the only
place where kids are getting any actual
coaching it's not about basketball it's
how do I self-regulate and how do I calm
down and what does movement skills look
like so we have to I think Be Clever
enough to look at some other
opportunities to support and right now
you know there's positive coaching
Alliance and some of these things but
who teaches volunteer coaches how to
coach kids it doesn't happen well and I
think a lot of you know as we were
talking about before where you know your
kids often don't want to hear the
message from you but they can better
hear it from other people in their lives
and oftentimes that could be a coach and
so youth coaches did get into the game
of a little bit of like you know
teaching kids how to take care of their
tissues and you know telling kids they
do need to sleep and maybe get off their
phones like that would be such a support
for I think all of us parents who are
trying really hard with the known yeah
within our own homes you know sometimes
that outside voice is really what kids
need to hear to actually try to make
change which hear it from their parents
no they can't hear from their parents
but man if we had our youth coaches out
there saying hey you guys really need to
put your phone down and get eight hours
of sleep if you want to perform all in
the soccer game tomorrow and hey you
guys should probably eat a few
vegetables and hey here's this two
dollar foam roller like if your calves
are sore you can do some input I mean
that alone would make a huge difference
right uh but how dare you you know
how dare you volunteer because it's
tricky It's Tricky it's really
complicated it shouldn't be but it is
right and you know where we'll we'll let
you know how the experiment goes you
know when our kids well also you know on
the subject of like the White House and
stuff like that is it correct that you
have worked with the president is this
true that's correct like can you con is
this like two percent
what is it what are we talking about
here uh we
have a friend who is uh the physical
therapist and Coach to was to President
Obama and also to President Biden and
he's a good friend of ours and says hey
we need help with resources or do you
have ideas for this or how do we solve
this problem and I think we can say now
because he's just a citizen but one of
the strangest experiences we had is
making an air gapped computer full of
Mobility drills and things where I talk
directly to President Obama that was
very uncomfortable for me
but and and little strategies you know
like we're obviously huge fans of
standing desks but um Obama was writing
his next book and he finds that he can
concentrate the most and the best when
he is sitting and so he but he also was
uncomfortable and couldn't figure out a
good sitting setup so we consulted with
him on okay here's sort of a sitting
desk setup where you can still manage to
get some movement in and you know fidget
and be able to keep your brain alive but
actually be in a sitting position I mean
it's really like minor stuff like that
but that makes a difference in the end
it's pretty cool how do we keep weight
on a aging executive I mean this is
these are the real questions how do we
you know aging executive you know
whoever is doing this job how can we
support them so they can do the job the
best that's really and we we have put
our name in the Hat although no no one's
come calling but our name is in the Hat
to be on the president's Physical
Fitness Council
brainer we would love to do that I mean
that would really be like you know an
amazing thing are you politics we have
something to contribute no one's come
calling so well I'm I'm setting you up
for that layup and uh and and you know
on the subject of keeping uh President
Obama on the basketball court right well
yes that's very true
um you know one this is a great allegory
for anything we're talking about
President Obama is a great athlete and
very competitive he's said as much
and one of the things that was happening
was he would play basketball in the at
the White House and he was ruining
a lot of cabinet members and staff
members they were having catastrophic
injuries the most dangerous sport for a
middle-aged person he was burning out a
step they were like tearing their ACLS
you know the most dangerous sport for
middle-aged people is basketball because
you go from zero to sprinting don't have
the tissues you haven't exposed yourself
to when's last time you jumped rope much
less cut well I think it's now been
surpassed by pickleball though
um that's true I don't know if we have
the perfect data on that but we think
but then I think that's that's the
allegory for how can you be prepared to
come off the couch and theoretically
come out intact and have more fun
especially when the game ready when the
president asks you to play basketball
will you be ready yeah that's what I
want yeah without having to sacrifice
your ACL
um this was super fun you guys I I
really appreciate your time I I'm a huge
fan of the work that you're doing I
think it's really thank you so much
um and the new book built to move uh you
know it's got like we talked about the
10 chapters which kind of goes through
Siri Adam all of these practices that
are very easily incorporated into uh
into our lives and and obviously you
know super important to keep us moving
and stable and mobile and flexible and
all the good stuff and uh I might just
start practicing
and let us know if you have any blind
spots and we're really grateful to have
to that's a whole other podcast Juliet
but we'll get to it let's do it yeah we
can that you and I can sit down and and
have a suffer Fest slash uh recovering
lawyer retired lawyer conversation as
well I look forward to that thank you so
much for having us it was really fun to
chat really really really cool so if
people want to check you out obviously
pick up the book uh build to move but
the readystate.com you've got tons of
materials and programs there your
YouTube channel the ready State as well
you know I'm doing videos and on
Instagram anywhere else you want to
direct people that's it those are the
two things builtomove.com all right
thank you so much
cheers
plants